Council may
approach
this is the children and family law
Committee of the New Hampshire House of
Representatives meeting on Tuesday
January 16th in the Legislative Office
Building I open the hearing on House
Bill
1667 relative to establishing a
department for children youth and
families and invite representative Jr to
come to the witness table and many of
our committee are viewing this hearing
from their homes and we will be
collecting for them any written
materials that are handed out and uh
even though it's we few we band of
brother um there are many members who
will be listening in on what we're doing
today so thank you representative please
present your bill good morning chairman
uh for the record representative po
representing the towns of
Dunbarton hooks at Allenstown and epsom
here to present um as the second
co-sponsor house bill 1667 and in
support of the
bill um first you may notice it's a long
bill it's only a long bill because we
have to replace the same phrase
throughout the statute um the phrase
being division of children youth and
families to the Department of Children
Youth and families effectively this what
eight page bill or so nine-page bill um
10 page bill
is taking what is currently a very large
Department buried within
DHHS um last count that I have from
house finance was roughly 775 positions
within this
department you uh I saw that the
assistant commissioner is here um or the
um Deputy Commissioners here you might
get a better
number of the roughly 5,000 employees
within that department or 4,000 sorry
3,000 employees within that department
this is almost 25% of
DHHS it is outside
of the rest of
DHHS and potentially the dep some of the
Department of Safety um including
Corrections probably the biggest
department in the state yet
organizationally it is buried two levels
below
almost three levels
below someone who would report to the
governor and executive counsel
directly so Department of Safety has a
direct report to the to the um executive
Council and Governor DHHS has a direct
report um as well as the the second
tiers or effectively direct reports to
the governor and Council however we have
the commissioner and then underneath
that would be an associate commissioner
and then underneath that becomes the
director for
DCF um I'm going to turn in an
organization chart so people understand
the makeup of the department I can also
turn in um some documentation if you
guys are interested showing the number
of employees in the department
underneath the director of DC what how
many copies do you have I have 20 would
you like some eventually yeah okay thank
you I would say hand them to the one
nearest you but that's me so I get it so
I will also if you're interested hand in
a couple of pages I can get these
printed out before I leave that show and
I can email them electronically show the
number of employees in the department so
underneath
DCF um there is the cunu center which is
a large group of people um the cunu
center is about 130 people there is also
foster care there is child placement
Services there there's a number of
different departments when all is said
and done in child prot ction
Services um I think there's over 500
people if I can find the page in this um
in this
chart uh
oops we we are
um Child Protection Services are
531 and that was from last year's budget
cycle
we've had a high couple of high-profile
cases in the last couple of years I
think we could nickname this the harmony
Montgomery bill I bring up her name
because here's a a perfectly good
example of the unfortunate part about
not having the necessary transparency
within
government who do you go to if you can't
find the and get access to the direct
supervisor easily in a case that's not
being addressed in correctly or their
supervisor or how many ever layers
between that person and the
director people know who their executive
counselor is if they have a problem they
can reach out to their executive
counselor and say hey I I'm not getting
the attention we need there there
there's clearly an issue my son or
daughter is not getting the protective
services that they
need I want you to look in into this and
that executive counselor can easily pick
up the phone and make a call and find
out what's going
on to some extent that can be done
through State reps and State Senators
but not as
effectively obviously all of these cases
are highly confidential which makes it
hard to deal with what do you do about
sharing this information um with a an
elected official and maybe we need to
create a car out such that a small group
of people like the executive Council
information could be shared with so that
the executive council members um each
one who represents 20% of the state can
make the necessary phone
calls what we see is an issue today of
inappropriate triage of cases and
insufficient resources in cases that
need help and overuse of resources in
cases that should be
dismissed every case where resources are
put State resources are put chasing the
wrong family we're short changing the
kid who needs
[Music]
help we don't need another Haron in
Montgomery at the end of the day um the
fact that two years went by in that case
or 18 months shows that there's some big
gaps in this department and while I
appreciate what the department has in
terms of being able to Link services
from within DCF to some of the other
Visions within
DHHS the reality is there's some major
structural gaps need to be addressed and
the best way to address this is to have
the transparency that would happen if
the department was by
itself so in that sense it's a
housekeeping
bill I there's probably people in the
audience behind me who would not say
moving a department out to it to its own
division would be or a division out to
its own Department would be a
housekeeping bill but at some
level all we're doing there's no dollars
associated with it all we're moving is a
group of people who do not have any
direct oversight via the executive
branch to a department from a division
to a department that actually does have
direct oversight by the executive
branch um in terms of the fiscal note I
will comment um there was a line in here
about needing to buy additional
equipment computers infrastructure
office Etc um obviously these people
have cubicles and equipment today I
don't understand why that in that
couldn't necessarily be allocated to
their new facility just changing the
reporting structure doesn't require us
to buy new infrastructure new
computers um it might mean a transfer of
assets at some level I'm not even saying
the department couldn't be collocated
within DHHS for the purpose purpose
of of housing all we're trying to do at
this level is make sure that there's
some executive oversight of this
department so we don't have another
Harmony
Montgomery um with that I'll close my
testimony unfortunately the prime
sponsor couldn't be here relative to
child care and and weather related stuff
so I am pinch itting for her today I
think that's it may I ask a question
absolutely
I see that greater accessibility and
transparency and
availability is always a good goal and I
know that as chairman of DHHS
oversight I have the honor of hearing a
report each month from the commissioner
of DHHS or the
deputy but anytime I want to hear from
DCF I just ask for the director to be
scheduled and the director is there I do
this with Mr Lipman from Medicaid and
all the different agencies within
DHHS and what difference would it make
for me or indeed any representative
calling up the director uh by moving the
director into being a commissioner so in
that case it wouldn't make a difference
the issue is in in the child protective
statutes um either for good reasons or
bad these are highly confidential cases
there's a lot of them right to have 700
almost 800 employees this is a
significantly a significant Department
in terms of
size by no means am I saying we don't
need these Services what I'm saying is
we need better oversight of these
services and
allowing maybe allowing in the statutes
that information could be shared with
with a small select few meaning
executive
counsel you can bring up a confidential
case as a parent with an elected
official today the way the statutes are
written it's really hard to deal with
that you could theoretically bring it up
um an active case with
um and we could make the changes to the
statutes there to bring it up with your
state representative so your state
representative could in fact call the
director of DCF
um last year in a sorry two years ago in
a bill we were able to make the change
from a criminal misdemeanor level P
penalty meaning potentially facing jail
time for sharing confidential
information to making it a violation
such that if if it was important enough
to risk the violation you could at least
start the dialogue with an elected
official today the average parent
doesn't have that option because Because
unless they're willing to face an
expense of violation there is no way for
them to share this information with an
elected official to get the help they
need could that not be put in a bill to
make that happen irrespective of whether
DCF is in an agency of DHHS or a
separate um Department
absolutely that is a positive change
absolutely I'm not disagreeing with that
what I'm trying to say is this is one
Department that's several tiers down
from the executive Council and the
governor unlike the other Departments of
equal size DHHS is a really large
department when you have really large
departments unfortunately it leads to
some net inefficiencies now it is good
um that let's say DCF needs is working
with a
family and they need additional benefits
through one of the other child benefit
programs because of um because the
family doesn't have enough income or
something the fact that that information
can be shared internally to help them
get the the resources is great that is
one of the benefits
today the way it's
structured
however because of the confidentiality
and because of where it is located
within D
DHHS we have this Gap where there's
insufficient transparency to
operations and greater transparency
leads to Greater government
performance once again could that
transparency not be uh better built into
what we have now as DCF as we all know
continues to improve from where it
was absolutely and and and maybe I
believe the Deputy Commissioner might be
testifying um think
smiling so I assume she'll she will step
up to testify she filled out a pin card
so she can testify she can testify uh I
believe there are potentially
transparency reforms the issue and I
would make the argument every case
should be
available at the same level it would in
terms of information that it would be if
it had been filed with the Supreme Court
so you guys may not see a bunch of
information that goes to the Supreme
Court but in a Supreme Court
case um let's say there's a child abuse
case involving a minor right they're
only using initials there's certain
information that is prohibited but they
do allow some level of content of what's
going on unfortunately that level of
content is not available today I would
be all in favor of figuring out how to
create some sort of structure to allow
greater transparency within the
department what I don't want to see is a
family who's complaining or a mom who's
complaining about a child not getting
the time or attention that they need and
It Go for for 18
months likewise on the other side I
don't want to see a family complaining
about hey my child is
fine but there's a house down the street
where there's rampant drug abuse and
those children aren't aren't get are are
being neglected aren't getting the time
and attention you need but you're
focusing on my children who are doing
really well right same town that
testimony happened um last week or two
weeks ago my point is there are issues
and coming from the engineering world I
would call it or engineeringmedical
world I would call it triage at the end
of the day figuring out how to vet cases
well is a tough thing I'm not I'm not
trying to minimize that task at all it
is really hard to do that
well however I do believe that greater
transparency and accountability to the
executive
branch is where some of that those
reforms Could Happen which is why we
have other major departments reporting
directly up to the executive counsel and
the
governor this one does not um one of the
questions was asked was relative to the
funding of the directorship right and
what the position yeah we can figure out
an appropriate position within the St
salary classification codes financial
aid right comparable to whatever the
current pay is but because the director
is now somebody who's nominated and
confirmed by the executive Council there
is some level of authority in in that
reporting structure that is greater than
anything today so to answer your
question at the highest level by putting
the direct link between the executive
Council of the governor and the head of
dcyf I believe we're going to see the
reforms we need thank you any further
questions for the representative
representative
McMahon thank you Mr chairman
H specific to what you testified earlier
that the inappropriate triage of cases
and then
to provide resources to investigate
cases so they don't go in the wrong
direction do we not or is based your
statement today is we do not have the
resources to do the job correctly in the
first place under the current structure
no we misappropriate resources today so
there is insufficient resources to
address the actual cases because of an
effort of focus and triage and some
cases get excessive effort that
shouldn't happen follow up Mr chair
follow up then specific to that are the
people that you're referring to not
trained to do the job that they are
required to
do I'm not sure if it's training or bias
I I'm too far removed I and and in all
fairness right you may or may not be
aware of my personal case so I there's a
certain inherent bias right from what I
saw but I can tell you the department
spent four months chasing a case that
could have been solved in 18
hours and that's four months with
multiple attorneys and multiple people
and 300 Pages worth of Discovery and
whatever
else they spent time on none of which
needed that tells me there's a
management issue not at the senior level
I believe that's the side that's fine
there's a middle ma a middle management
level issue somewhere between the casew
worker and maybe the branch supervisor
or manager right so we have the Conway
and the conquered and the Manchester
branches somewhere between maybe that
branch manager and
down is where the issue is having spoke
having spoken with several attorneys who
deal with dcyf cases on on a regularity
they can tell which branches or which
whatever conquer Division versus Conway
Division versus Manchester they can tell
which divisions perform better than
others just by the just by the clients
that they end up seeing and by the
information coming through the case so
some of those divisions do really well
and some do
not any further questions representative
McMahon yes
uh thank you Mr chairman there it is
again I'll be redundant thank you Mr
chairman that's okay I thought I'd
stipulate that when I said it the first
time consider yourself stipulated thank
you your honor okay it's under appeal
I'm sure indeed it is the uh the issue
wanted to go after here it's I've being
on the oversight Committee in my career
here over 20 years is that we found uh
that a quick response takes place when
the oversight committee is made aware of
the subject matter and they already have
a due process authority to call the
authorities having jurisdiction to come
in front of them if we um that being
said is that also not being uh exploited
to facilitate doing the right thing as
you as you state performance for our
citizens so so um if I may I I I'm not
sure exploited is the right word so let
me offer uh taken advantage of right in
terms of that the citizens are aware of
this and reach out to you guys I don't
think that information is out there so
that may be one of the things that comes
out of this is to make sure this group
of people the oversight committee
is available their contact information
is provided so that when a citizen says
Hey time out I've got a problem right
either end of the
spectrum it's a Continuum that they know
who to reach out to I can tell you
personally after my my
um series of events with dcyf in
starting in 2021 after that case was
public and in the press and closed I had
17 phone calls from from parents who
felt like they weren't getting the help
they need or they were a victim of an
aggressive
Department that's a lot of phone
calls any other questions U one last one
Mr chairman why
not relative to the fiscal note when it
states the department uh on the last
page repo yep says does not provide for
the transfer of certain
staff uh my question is can we
facilitate what we have as
Resources with with additional Direction
and job description to meet the service
requirements that you are that well that
are represented in the
bill so there are a lot of ways to do
this um relative to that footnote about
transfer of non DCF staff as I am aware
there are I believe 33 attorney
positions reporting through the office
of the commissioner not directly
underneath the department the director
of
DCF those attorneys handle a lot of the
casework some of which might be for DHHS
some of which is all is DCF related um
maybe the Deputy Commissioner can better
speak to that I believe that's the
positions they're talking about but I
don't know I'm willing to try and figure
out how to make that group as well I
believe that department needs the legal
support a lot of cases get tossed into
the legal domain maybe
prematurely um and it just takes at some
level right we are taking people that
are case workers when they run into a
road block it goes up to an attorney
especially if if you get an attorney
involved early in the case so I think
that is the positions they're referring
to but I I better I can't answer because
I don't know thank you sir thank you Mr
chairman you're welcome representative B
thank you Mr chairman thank you I'd say
good morning but I don't agree with
that um you had brought up a couple of
times Harmony Montgomery and I came a
little late so I apologize for that sure
um so how would this bill help a case
like
that so the issue is today a citizen
doesn't know where to turn um I think
you miss missed it I will be handing out
the organization chart right the the
director report you haven't seen it yet
the director reports to the associate
commissioner of the associate
Commissioners reports up to the
commissioner right so there is no
published org chart so when Jane Doe
case worker stops at your door and says
hey I've got I I want to work with you
and the parent doesn't feel like they're
getting a response it's not clear who
they call after that at some level we
could deal with that with a policy right
that um here's my business card I'm a
I'm a case worker here's my direct
supervisor right and that information is
shared so if you don't like what I'm
doing call my direct supervisor
unfortunately none of that information
is
available I do believe there are issues
where people aren't getting the response
they need so unfortunately the mom in
the in the harmony Montgomery case never
got the response she needed she wrote
all the way up through the mayor of
Manchester and fell on deaf ears I don't
want to see that I want to make sure
there's someone in the executive branch
who you can pick up the phone and this
is to the point earlier well there's an
oversight committee that people can call
today I've been a State Rep this is my
ninth year I didn't know that until
today so if I didn't know that I'm
pretty certain out of the 1.3 million
citizens in New Hampshire that's a small
group of people who are aware of the
oversight Committee of DCF and DHHS so
something that comes positive out of
this is greater publicity about there's
another way to reach out to someone
who's an elected official to get the
help thank you did I answer your
question yes it does this is a problem
to me that's in search of a solution and
this bill proposes one solution
educating the executive Council and all
the state reps whom to go
to is another solution that is other
than separating out a whole uh agency
from a department would you agree that
is a possible solution absolutely I the
reason I think this is this is warranted
is we're talking about a budget that's
$150 million it's not an insignificant
amount of money each year okay in terms
of
resources it oversees important
functions like foster care it oversees
important
functions um child placement functions
if
necessary these are important things
when this is the one case where
government intrudes within the the
family structure in a significant way
more so than any other place in
government yet it is it's not its own
Department reporting up to the governor
and executive counsel it's buried down
below an existing structure there is no
other way to create the transparency
this might be the sledgehammer to
solving the problem I'm willing to
acknowledge that there might be lots of
changes between this request
and what right and what could be done to
improve transparency but clearly there
is a transparency need and an
accountability need that has not been
addressed on both ends of the spectrum
harming Montgomery for lack of
resources myself and 17 other families
on the other end yeah we're now
repeating ourselves including myself so
thank you so much and the chair
recognizes uh Deputy Commissioner DHHS
Marissa hen and director of dcyf Jeff
fer please come on
up thank
you just for everybody just for
everybody
welcome thank you good
morning you have all the time you need
and it begins when you want but the mic
was on so you just turned it off there
we go and we're back good morning
Marissa hen Deputy
Commissioner Jeff leer DCF director
great and I'll let um director fler
start off and and chime in as needed but
thanks for the opportunity
yeah thank you m um yeah good morning
yeah just um uh let me respond to some
of the
concerns that I heard first of all uh I
we at the department are not in favor
and at DCF not in favor of separating
DCF out of DHHS for very good reasons
there's a lot of synergy there's a lot
of coordination there's a lot of sharing
of
resources um there's a lot of
camaraderie a lot of uh leadership um uh
work going on um and not only that but
around the country around the nation
this is a pretty typical scenario where
the the the dcyf of the state is part of
a Department of Human Services and
that's basically because of the Synergy
and and the uh the coordination let me
address the uh transparency issue and
accountability
issue um I appear um every month with
the children's oversight committee which
which is uh uh Senator Whitley and and
many others um and I report every
meeting um and they have direct access
to me and uh in addition to that um we
have the courts that oversee what we do
and uh hear all the important cases and
make decisions about placement and uh
removal of children and reunite
unification of children and so we're
constantly working in the court system
there's the office of a child advocate
who whose main job is to oversee the
work of DCF they have direct access to
our records uh they go into the same
Software System that our case workers
have that I have um to access cases and
they can pull out things that they have
concerns about that they red flag that
they have problems with or questions
about um they sit in uh we meet with
them regularly and different aspect
aspects of the organization we have a
dcyf Advisory Board which also includes
legislators um about half the members
are are legislators on the DCF um board
which uh representative long uh is a
longtime member um so there's a lot of
accountability we also have a
constituent
relations and believe it or not but I
get a lot of calls directly to my cell
phone from families from Forester
parents from Kinship Caregivers and I
respond personally to these to these um
uh calls we also send them off to our
constition relations which is a really
great professional staff that
investigates um every call that we get
in of concern so if I get a legislator
which I get many times who call me and
say Jeff we have a problem we're hearing
about a problem with a certain case we
send out our constituent relations to
really investigate to really double
check and to really figure out and
investigate what's going on here and to
make recommendations for REM in the
situation there's also Kasa who also
work with us um very closely and also
challenge us and and um uh you know call
out things that they may US disagree
with as well as well as agree with and
support us so there's a lot of
transparency with the with
dcyf I also attend I've attended almost
every governor and councel and uh called
upon to ask questions directly from
councils uh counselors
um so uh I'll stop there for a moment
but if transparency is the issue there's
a lot of accountability a lot of
transparency without removing DCF from
the
department and there's a lot of
oversight of our
department and so uh as far as
inefficiencies um it's the opposite
being part of Department creates a lot
of efficiencies and
Synergy as far as who to call we have
hotlines we have Central intake and uh I
go out I've met with uh forced parents
um with Kinship Caregivers um with men's
groups uh many of the the the parents
and and forcer parents that are within
and providing services to our kids at
DCF and continue to um reach out um so
I'll stop there for for this moment and
if there's any
questions representative long than you
Mr
chairman uh with respect to sharing of
resources could you could you you know
I'm thinking Behavioral Health is one um
if this department was if they were to
be their own
Department how would that work would
there be a back charge or I I'm not sure
how that would uh and I know there's
others other than vehicle house yeah
great question um I think we share the
same question and concern honestly um
currently we have our Bureau for
children's Behavioral Health under the
division for Behavioral Health um and
yet because we all share the same home
base we're able to seamlessly coordinate
um on those cases so in other words when
families need services that are Beyond
um simply dcf's perview we're able to
step in and help connect them with
treatment um help them connect them with
with Services both um acute as well as
um preventive I'll give one example by
the way so I think you all know that as
part of this uh children system of care
portfolio um Hamstead hospital is one of
the key um components of our Continuum
obviously for those for those youth who
are who are most acute um you know we
estimate that somewhere between 30 and
50% of the um patients we serve in this
acute environment have experienced um
abuse or neglect they may or may not
have open cases with
dcyf um but there's a tremendous amount
of overlap and so what we're able to do
as a team bringing together multiple
divisions director fler director Fox The
Bureau for children's Behavioral Health
is really look at what the needs of
these families are holistically and how
we ensure we're building a Continuum
that's responsive to their needs so I
think that's actually your question
lends itself to a concern we have which
is would we end up siloing ourselves
more um given that we um we are serving
many of the same families through a
highly integ
um Behavioral Health oriented system not
simply the traditional um features of
sort of Juvenile Justice and um child
welfare could I follow follow me uh the
the other question is with respect to uh
I I have also felt the middle the middle
management type has been
disconnected um could you can you
address that I mean I'm finding that in
a lot in the the circuit courts and you
know I find in a lot of departments that
you know when you get to the middle it's
it's inconsistent a little bit yeah um
could you address that sure I mean we
are we're committed to continuing to
develop our Workforce and I think you
know that that includes um not only
recruitment coming out of a very
difficult um labor market uh during and
after the pandemic um but also in terms
of how do we build um how do we build up
leaders who are able to exercise
leadership at that middle level um
without things having to rise to
director fer or my level and I think we
see really powerful examples um of
success in that regard that don't
necessarily make the news um but we're
continuously engaging in sort of a
teaming based coaching oriented culture
um in which we use individual cases even
last week I can think of one that
crossed all the parts that we were just
talking about um Behavioral Health DCF
Hamstead hospital to sort of bring to
the for the issues that were that are
going on in that in the life of that
child and family and identify very
critically how are we best coordinating
to meet that family's needs and where
are we potentially seeing room for
improvement so so I think it's um it's
happening to an extent uh but it is uh
undoubtedly going to be more challenging
if if if we're sort of the silos are
further apart in my
opinion thank
you as I look at this uh
flowchart
I can see an issue coming up where
related
groups someone will say we got to bring
in one of these other related groups in
the conversation oh no they moved across
town as opposed to their two cubes down
so to me this flowchart makes the case
for dcyf being part of this family under
your right purview um do you find the
fact that these
various children's issues and mental
health issues are
together
advantageous no it's a good question and
I think um as representative hul
indicated there are some unique
functions um and responsibilities DCF
has particularly in terms of its
relationship with the courts um and its
historically uh very powerful
responsibility around um impacting
family structure that we take seriously
but thanks to the reforms that have
occurred over the past five plus years
um under under director ribsam um
director fleer's predecessor we really
are moving in a direction where it's
it's no
longer um a surprise or a controversy
that uh what families need is um is a
level of support and coordination and
that includes not just with Behavioral
Health but also with our eligibility
system um as he said for things like um
food stamps for things like Medicaid
when they're qualified and so in
addition to potentially some of the I'm
not actually as worried about us
physically being separate to be honest
we have a really Dynamic team of of
folks who can cross the river and
coordinate it's awfully nice being
collocated I think my bigger concern is
You're Building Systems um that have
some really major barriers so we take
privacy very seriously in New Hampshire
um just talking with our um director
over our it systems what we would have
to build in order to allow for data
sharing agreements and order to allow
for passage of information internally
would be a major undertaking of of
significant financial cost but also with
more separations and so you know it's
it's interesting when I I um most
recently worked in the state of Utah
where Governor Spencer Cox actually
brought um different parts of the Health
and Human Services Continuum together
with the same arguments of transparency
and efficiency so it's kind of makes me
chuckle a little bit because I think we
share the desire to be high quality
transparent committed to continuous
Improvement good stewards of public
resources I think we do that best when
we are um when we're combined under one
Department as you know I chair the
special committee on the Family Division
of circuit court and we had 14 hours of
public testimony we had subcommittee
meetings and what we found much to our
Delight was as we got going in the
subcommittees talking with Judiciary
they having sat in already on everything
else or watch the the video of it they
had already started to implement some of
the things so you know some of us had
these wonderful bills we were going to
turn in requiring the Judiciary to do
this or that but because of hearings and
hearings like this they said oh that's
pretty good yeah let's let's work
continuously on that and I I am watching
DCI DCF doing that um I was left out
earlier as chairman of DHHS oversight I
can bring him in periodically uh as well
as all the other groups um that there
has been great change and I would you
say that there are things that you've
heard today that might strike a
responsive cord uh on we can start doing
this or we're doing it but we can up it
or that's a good idea have either of you
heard anything like that out of today's
hearing yeah AB absolutely and we really
want to um thank the committee and the
bill sponsors for giving us that
opportunity to be reminded of just how
important it is to be um to fulfill in a
very visible way our commitments toward
transparency coordination clearly making
sure that um you know when the child
advocate picks up the phone and calls us
as she does uh or her team does you know
each week that we're able to touch base
on the Myriad things going on and
identify root cause identify the types
of Staff training and middle management
leadership that um that these cases
deserve I mean fundamentally these are
families who deserve nothing less than
to have their needs met in a way that um
that our government has been set up to
do and I think when we start to create
those separations um I really worry
about there being chasms in our ability
to uphold that commitment to um
communication and transparency that you
all um are
articulating any further questions
representative Bickford thank you Mr
chairman thank
you has DCF are um been separated out in
the past I can remember at some point
things coming together I thought a good
question and what was the reasoning then
for bringing it under if you know yeah I
I don't believe so and and and uh uh
director Williams who's our our real Pro
um doesn't either I I think what you
this bill was brought
forward I wasn't aware of your promotion
counselor director of legislative
affairs so he said director um uh I I
don't believe so it um there was a prior
version of this same um policy uh
objective brought forward which might be
what's ringing a chord um that it was
there were there have been prior
discussions about it but it has not
occurred that aware
of I'll wait for John
okay thank you and thank you for your
testimony the final pink card will be
from representative Betty gay she asked
for three minutes we're running overtime
we heard at the chairman and vice
chairman meeting today that they are
asking because of so many bills we have
that if somebody doesn't have anything
new to bring they either wave off or
limit their testimony to anything new
new that you have for us that you
haven't heard
yet in no three minutes no no I'll just
take three
sentences oh working Silo to Silo as
this is the bill is accused of sounds
like you absolutely require physical
location collocation to communicate well
but I assume that nowadays most work is
done via the phone and
email this bill doesn't stop DCF
Communication in inter agency it adds
Clarity and accessibility for the public
which I think is becoming really well
known the need for that is becoming very
well
known any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony and
uh this concludes our
hearing on House Bill 1667 thank you for
coming and as much as I would like to
execute I can't because I don't have a
quorum so in a couple of weeks we will
so that gives the advantage that if
anyone wishes to speak to the bills
sponsors to propose an amendment one way
or the other based on anything you've
heard anything you're thinking about in
the next two weeks we will be executing
this bill uh in two or three weeks so
you've got your chance to do it a chance
to polish things up and there we go and
we have another handout thank
you
you and this testimony this written
testimony we are receiving is for the
bill we are about to um have a hearing
on and I open the hearing on House Bill
1511 which is relative to the liability
for children with disabilities in
certain court ordered placements or
episodes of treatment and I cannot call
on anyone because I do not have any pink
cards I've done this a few times I
should have known should can I fill one
out afterwards or would you like it yes
you well you can but not only that more
importantly you may thank you you're
welcome okay uh good morning colleagues
my name is representative Deb Hobson and
I represent East Kingston and
Kingston along with the honorable chair
uh in district 14 of Rockingham County I
was contacted by members of the uh by a
member of the Department of Education to
file this measure that corrects an
inaccuracy in the law about how the New
Hampshire Department of Education is
notified of an episode of
treatment currently the law states that
the courts would notify the doe about an
episode of treatment however courts are
not involved in an episode of treatment
placement uh so I'm simply introducing
the measure and I'm joined by uh Rebecca
fet today uh from the Department of
Education she will explain the measure
further and take any questions and what
else and thank you very much fill out a
pink card and I will fill out a pink
card thank you I will also fill out the
pink card thank you so much my clerk
loves pink cards my name is Rebecca frad
I'm um the administrator for the Bureau
of special education at the Department
of
Education um we asked for represent
Hobson to introduce this bill for us as
it was passed last year through hb2 and
there were two um pieces that just
needed to be corrected within the bill
uh it as representative Hobson had
stated it states that the notification
about an EP episode of treatment excuse
me um will come from the courts however
it does not come from the courts it
comes from either DHHS or the school
district so we're just adding that in
there so it clarifies the language um
it's pretty beyond that it's pretty self
explanatory we um currently have a fund
where we reimburse districts and pay to
the schools that students go to for an
episode of treatment so all the finances
have already been worked out it's
already being paid it's just a
clarification in the
law any
questions the last time I introduced
something as just a housekeeping measure
the hearing went on for two hours they
totally destroyed my bill and what they
came out with was something fantastic so
I'm hoping to redeem the phrase just a
housekeeping Bill representative
bigford thank you Mr chairman and thank
you uh for answering my question uh
episode uh in this case what does that
mean uh episode sure so and um DHHS has
uses the language episode of treatment
um they could probably explain it a
little better than I can but it's
typically when a student has a mental
health issue that they need to receive
treatment for um they may need to go
into a placement it could be that they
have suicidal ideations it could be that
they have other issues that that need to
be treated in what isn't considered a
special education setting but could be
consider is considered a mental health
um facility or mental health
treatment um want to follow up no thank
you I think that covers it for me
anybody
else representative Vice chairman
L thank thank you Mr chairman um so just
for my
clarity this is uh there's there's been
a short uh with notifying Department of
Education and this addresses
that can you repeat I'm sorry can you
repeat that there there's been a uh
there's been a short in Department of
Education being notified of some of this
oh no we are notified it's just we're
clarifying who we're notified by because
the currently the legisl the law says
that will be notified by the courts but
for an episode of treatment it doesn't
go through the court system it goes
through DHHS and their Bureau of
children's Behavioral Health so we are
just clarifying that that's how we would
be notified because the courts aren't
involved in all it's mixed in with our
court ordered placement language that's
why there was some confusion because we
pay out two um funds one is court
ordered placements and now we pay out
episod of treatment so the language just
got a little fuzzy okay very good thank
you
seeing nothing further thank you so much
for your testimony and your pink cards
this concludes the hearing on Bill House
Bill uh
151 and I've got a few things for the
committee and since I think the
committee is uh most of the committee
members are listening in um there's just
a few things that I need to uh present
to you when I find
them
this is for anybody and everybody
um normally we don't have so many people
absent and what happened last week is
handouts were handed around in a huge
pile of paper landed right here and what
we will be asking what I've been asked
to ask you is um if you see a vacant
chair start a pile for that person and
then at the end of the day put that
person's name on the top sheet paper
clip it together so you're making a
packet and that can be given to the
individual representative when he or she
comes to the next committee meeting and
representative Bickford has pretty much
started doing that with several of the
folks um and um
so yeah yeah so um anyway that's just
been asked because the poor clerk last
week um representative ball was in a sea
of
paper also traditionally anybody coming
to testify here folks um the um clerk
gets two copies I believe one for you
one for the
files and when handouts are started
around make sure that if there are not
enough some people uh haven't done a
head count to see how many people there
are in the committee uh I think there's
16 that means you need 17 handouts if
you want each one of us to get one it is
not necessarily the job of the committee
assistant or research to run up and
downstairs to make copies um graciously
they will sometimes but they have other
duties as well and any
overage after things have been handed
out and empty seats get theirs any
overage goes back to either
representative Bickford or
representative now known as Gibbons um
not quite sure where those Stacks wind
up going but that's where they go at
least
initially
um we in the chairs are encouraged to
line up hearings well in
advance because we've got so much to do
and we want to make it come out even we
have to get the early bills of which
there are several out heard and exact by
February 13th in this committee February
15th in the house which means we got to
work really uh
speedily um the trouble with planning
way ahead is sometimes events have a way
of interfering if this was more than a
heavy Frost out here we wouldn't be
meeting well I also discovered we're not
meeting next week because it's primary
and I thought I was a good little wise
chairman by asking everybody is that
okay and only one person said he's got
to do something and I promised the vice
chair we wouldn't have any fun while he
was gone but what I didn't realize is a
a it was a house policy not to have it
and B the reason is many of the bills
are obviously presented by
legislators who might need to be
involved in the primary day so just a
long way of saying we have to be
flexible depending on weather and other
circumstances but we'll work together to
get it
done also on executing bills a bill may
be exec the same day is heard now we
used to have a little disclaimer note
sometimes in the calendar from a
committee saying a bill may be exact the
same day it's heard well some of us
forgot so now there is a blanket
statement right here in last week's
calendar page three that says pursuant
to house rule 44b executive session on
bills may be taken up during the day in
which they are
heard my rule of and it doesn't say this
but the general rule of thumb is with
consultation of the vice chair a ranking
member we want to make sure this is
bipartisan I really don't want to take
up and exec a bill we just heard if
there is a good bit of division in the
committee at best that means you folks
can as I keep exhorting people go off
with the bill sponsors and try to square
the circle try to find out what were the
objections does that objection warrant
killing the bill or can that objection
be worked into the bill because it was
reasonable and that's going to take two
or three weeks to do it so I don't want
to exec a bill unless it's going to go
on consent or nearly so or in the case
of bills with fiscal notes it's going to
be unanimous or nearly so but on the
regular calendar um that's that way when
exact days are called in advance if you
cannot be here you can get a
replacement um we if I may speak to that
we sure we used to do it this way way
back and then that was changed because
there was a lot of complaints from the
public that and even the representatives
because they they felt it was nobody's
even taking time to hear them I guess
but the thing is going on today which is
different is they have uh a place where
people can write in sure and they say
right on it it doesn't close until noon
so they think that they're writing in
and people go looking at it and the fact
is no we don't even get to see it
because we've already voted it out so it
kind of rubs the public the wrong way is
my my point this is why I won't exec a
bill where there's significant division
in the committee because you and others
may wish to read what they're writing in
if we are of one mind that this is
either the best billson sliced bread or
the one from the you know the what's on
the other end of the river sticks
um I doubt there will be controversial
comments coming in that would sway us
one way or the other so those are the
ones I will go ahead and exact but I
will limited what other committee chairs
do in broadening it is up to them I just
want to share the history with you oh I
appreciate that if you don't get it from
me check with John I appreciate that um
one other thing uh that they have
stressed upstairs in our um chair's
meeting is no
food no coffee in a committee room
because there's new rugs and I've not
yet gotten an answer to um if somebody
spills on the rug should we take their
name and send them a bill for cleaning
I'm hoping the answer will be absolutely
yes we will but no coffee guys gals um
no food I bring my lunch that means I
have to go to the cafeteria or sit on a
landing where there isn't a
rug um anything else in terms of
housekeeping committee wise because we
still have a few minutes
left uh from the committee only please
uh I think we're
set which
papers now that will be a committee
function you papers will come to the
closest person who then um it's
generally customary not for people who
aren't committee members to be up here
um
you made
it I did make
it I found it pretty tricky it wasn't
you know it wasn't as bad as I thought
but uh you know what I don't like is
when it's dark out going home snowing
dark is bad enough well I start to get G
when I slow down yeah I S I was just
yeah I slipped making the turn on the
stores oh you know and when you come
down and you make the turn yeah I
started slipping and traffic was coming
towards me that was the only minor
situation I didn't see off I was
surprised
actually oh
boy what's that
we could end of the day we put these in
drop
yeah
enjo
well
joh hey
oh
I open the hearing on House Bill
1341 relative to the liability of
grandparents to provide assistance and
the prime sponsor is our very own
representative Bickford would you come
to the witness table and say what you
would like as the prime
sponsor and let the record show he has
already filled out his pink card and the
chair has already handed it over to the
clerk
okay thank you Mr chair uh my name is
representative David Beckford from new
dooro I also represent uh town of
Middleton and uh what I've brought
before you is uh HB House Bill
1341 and um it comes directly from the
review that was done that we paid
$116,000
for to the University of Colorado I
believe and it's very good I hope
everybody's read it um it's only 198
pages and what I have here this is the
actual what it looks like the
review um and what I did is I copied it
onto this P paper that I as a handout
for you this front
page it's just for reference and then if
you come down you'll see um
recommendations and what this is uh a
recommendation number seven from this
review and I'll read it for the record
it's pretty short either repeal the law
providing for grandparent liability to
support the children of their unwed
minor children or add more specification
to it there are numerous justifications
to eliminate it it is not a common issue
child support from the parent if able
should be
prioritized and establishing policies
for consistent treatment would require a
lot of time and resources for few
cases more specification would entail
whether to limit liability only to
public assistance
cases application to both the maternal
and paternal grandparents identification
of income to to be used in several other
specifications so that comes from page
uh 157 they do have uh more discussion
about it throughout the but it's really
becomes repetitious so that's why I
wanted to give you this and that's
really all I all I have for
you what is the liability of
grandparents
now um that they can be drawn into to
have to pay check
support for their
grandchildren most cases it would be
unwed pay child support of their
grandchildren assumes that the children
well cannot or will not do so no it's
more actually I'm not sure of how much
that used anymore it it can be actually
I'm not sure if they're addressing that
but there is another statute on that um
but this is uh they're talking about uh
unwed children and so the grandparents
now have to pay child
support um to someone the other
grandparents sometime wherever they are
could I ask the researcher please to
punch up if she hasn't done so already
RSA 167 colon 3-
littlea which is the statute that this
bill seeks
to
repeal yep
and since the vice chairman has beaten
you to
it would you would you read uh Vice
chairman the statute that this bill
seeks to
eliminate liability of
grand liability of grandparents
assistance rendered under this chapter
or RSA 161 to anyone who is the child
born of an unwed minor whose father or
mother grandparent of the child born how
an unwanted minor has a weekly income or
other resources more than sufficient to
provide reasonable subst
subsistence compatible with decency and
health may be recovered from such Grant
priate in the same manner and by the
same proceedings as provided in RSA 167
colon 2 and 167 colon 3 for recovery
from other legal liability relatives
so this
addresses children of unwed minor
children and the grandparents in
question have the income to be able to
do it in other words you're not
impoverishing
them okay so that's what this seeks to
remove yeah and uh why would you seek to
remove
it
because because they said to they it
could become very elongated they don't
think it's uh as you I pointed out it
says
uh you should uh be establishing
policies for consistent treatment would
require a lot of time and resources for
few very few cases more specification
would entail whether to limit the
liability only to public assistance
cases application to both the maternal
and paternal
grandparents and uh identification of
income to be used and several other
specif ific so there's a lot missing in
the Statue we could either they
recommend that we either elongate it and
make it very great specification but in
the end they're saying don't even bother
don't don't get in don't go there
they're
saying any questions from the panel of
four yes representative
MC man okay thank
you representative a specific to where
funds would then come come from is the
fall back would the fall back here if if
grandparents aren't available would be
the federal government or the state yeah
yeah I believe
so thank
you any further
questions do we know what other states
do regarding
this I don't I do I do
not
um I think they have pulled away from
that quite a lot um the fact of whether
you're wet or not if you're if
you of course if a minor gets wet then
they become emancipated and it becomes
their
responsibility to try and do it
do you know if uh this has been brought
up here
before I I can't say as I do recall
okay we've done some stuff on I know we
did a
stepparents and I think that we don't
hold them liable anymore okay because
they have no rights really uh but I
don't think grandparents we did this is
the sort of question that I love to ask
and the committee researcher loves to
answer do we have anything committee
researcher you're going to need to come
to the mic a
mic okay and you're going to need to
turn the mic
on then you're going to need to speak
into the mic
because it's in 167 it might be and it's
title four of the Social Security Act it
might be related to federal funds such
as tanif so I'm happy to look into that
for you because it's not very clear
could be a policy in the department uh
so I can look into that for
you so in other words if there's
something from the federal government
lurking in the background what we do
with this particular 1673 a may be
impacted so we need to find out yes and
it may change from state to state
because not every program is the same so
I can look into
it well since we cannot exec anything
today that would be a nice little
project I've never met anybody who more
loves to do term
papers well yes I wouldn't the people to
do the research and put out these
reviews um do them quite often like I
said they do a
contract um with the state and uh they
you know you talking people with
Doctorate Degrees and everything they
know they know this 4D better than any
of us do so that's why I took them at
their uh face value you might say when
they recommended
it well then if um you can provide to
the committee
researcher um how to find this expensive
report maybe a lot of her work is
already done yeah uh that is on the
child support uh website if it took me a
little few minutes to find it but it is
there and there's a link there and it
opens up the same thing plus I have it
in my computer on my cloud I should say
and I think I have an extra C I left a
copy here last time I spoke to it and so
it's either me or them and probably the
federal government too um but this one
just came out December 31st of
22 so we're just getting around to get
into the some of the recommendation and
um there seems to be in this one page
you handed out
some contact information or something it
would be helpful not only to to to
approach it from what is what do the
feds say but also approach it from what
this report says so we can come at the
answer to this question does this bill
if passed impact um anything else uh we
can come at it from a couple of
directions yeah uh I should
give my researcher
researcher
okay uh because that direct you right to
the page of the summary of
the of the uh
recommendations
yeah these I think I've told you before
but these come out every four years
is this something uh the
DHHS legislatively a on to everything I
seem to run know something
about no I'm sorry I didn't understand
the question well I was just trying to
figure out which way she was
pointing see we have two lawyers now on
the clock yeah and can you guys bring an
answer to the question that if House
Bill
1341 about Grandparents assistance being
removed I.E RSA 167 freea if that would
impact any of the wonderful programs
that any of our state agencies receive
money for you
may
approach I have to touch it then I have
to give it to
him
the mic on for you chairman parison
members of the children and family law
committee for the record my name is John
Williams I am the director of
legislative affairs for the Department
of Health Human Services and this does
take me back in time I think the last
time I've been testifying next to rips
and Bickford must have been a couple of
decades ago but it was but it was B no
we well he's he's definitely more
handsome and I'm definitely a little bit
more grayer so with that um with with
that uh the department on 1341 relative
to liability of grandparents to provide
assistance although I don't believe it's
reflected in the fiscal analysis of the
bill because when we did report back to
the LBA our analysis on it uh they Pro
possibly made a determination that it
was less than $10,000 and that's why
they didn't include that onto
legislation itself I represent to this
committee that is part of a recent audit
I believe it was through the LBA that
one of the areas that they did site was
a concern the LBA had a concern over
grandparent liability this this legis
LBA uh the legislative budget Assistance
Office uh at the state level uh and
because of that particular audit and I
will stand corrected if it was a federal
audit but I understood it to be an LBA
audit that this actually addresses one
of the corrective actions that they
would have relative to grandparent
liability uh and assessing the
legislation we believe that it would
have no impact to department
administration and we do think in terms
of a policy perspective totally your
consideration that it may be very
helpful um some of the areas that it
would capture and I think reverent
Bickford probably already touched upon
those uh matters that in cases for
example under child's support where you
have a I believe he's going to point me
to the right section that he's probably
already testified to I apologize I
wasn't here so I don't want to duplicate
testimony but uh grandparents who have
minor children who have children uh
their grandchildren uh are currently
under statute still liable for uh
reimbursement for certain expenditures
such as the the tanif um expenditure so
with that if you were to proceed in pass
this legislation I can represent to you
based upon our fiscal analysis which I
was a part of so I do have direct
knowledge of that that this has no
fiscal impact to the department or at
least not anticipated and we do believe
that it's in line with whether it's a
federal audit or the LBA audit
corrective action to doing this
legislation this legislation would be
responsive to that concern
representative long thank you Mr
chairman uh with respect to um matching
funding from the feds is is there
any uh with respect to
this I do you
know this was reviewed by the legal
councel uh for the underlying program
area and I believe in addition to that
I'm just pulling up my my notes because
I do have more extensive notes based
upon our fiscal analysis on this
legislation that this would not impact
either uh tanif or the uh Tana Federal
block grant that we receive great thank
you any other
questions yes representative McMahon
thank you Mr
chairman attorney Williams relative to
the funding uh a question as it as it
stands right right now with this law Rec
um this bill recommending a
change if the funding wasn't is not
coming from the
grandparents then where would that loss
of funding be recovered and does that
not increase the
cost that the matching amount with the
federal government would need to
reflect I will just defer for a second
to see if I can parse out the the
question so under the question that
you're posing that we have a grandparent
there is assumed liability for the
grandparent and the money that we're
collecting from that parent then would
go back to at least for the U percentage
of the uh federal funds or strike that
the state funds would go to our general
funds right is
that let me I'll we we raise it if
that's if the bill as it not the bill
the law as it current states that the
grandparents are
the secondary source
for for funding or reimbursement for
like T of uh spending if this uh this
bill passes and States they no longer
have that that responsibility or
liability in this case then does that
not
increase the uh cost for
the children being maintained by this
funding and uh with the Chairman's um um
permission because I typically do not
like to read from but I think it'll give
you an accurate answer to your question
so um this is an excerpt from our uh
financial analysis uh provided to the um
LBA this is not anything official from
the LBA this is officially from the
Department uh tanif is a federal block
grant program where the federal
government gives States money that must
be used for certain purposes and comply
with Federal requirements one of those
requirements is that the state must
require tanif recipients to assign
support rights to the state and
cooperate with the state efforts to
collect support and it provides a very
long Federal citation however however
this I think addresses your question
federal law does not require that the
grandparents of children of unwed minors
received tanif be liable for
support and that answers that thank you
sir so the state doesn't require it but
the state may do it if it
chooses
that is correct based upon the following
two sentences of this what I was reading
from okay before you go any other
questions I have one from uh the chair
recognizes um representative
sidal who uh sits as you can see right
over there would this requirement of
grandparents to financially support
their minor child's
child be similar to the grandparent
going to jail for a crime their minor
child
committed she's asking whoever is ready
to answer I I have to say represent
Bickford's uh comment that that's
rhetorical in nature I'd have to agree
with yeah so do I I agree okay it's it's
uh representative Sidell thank you for
the question uh they deem it
rhetorical
I keep those uh cards and texts coming
committee members only if you wish
anything else um for uh the
representative and
councel
wow seeing
none I close the hearing on House Bill
1341 and since we lack a quorum uh this
will be taken up at exec
session
in a couple of
weeks so thank you and we are done can
you believe it until
1:00
you're
serous what
that
first I'm going to Wade through the
snow
well
actually
this is the children and family law
Committee of the New Hampshire House of
Representatives on January 16th
2024 and I open the hearing on House
Bill
1266 FN permitting the recordings of
open Family Court proceedings by parties
in the chair Rec
recognizes the prime sponsor uh
representative Caitlyn
cab thank you Mr chairman and honorable
members of the child and family law
committee for the record my name is
representative Caitlyn cab and I
represent Rockingham District 17 the
town of
wiam this bill simply allows the right
of of parties that are part of a family
court proceeding to
record their proceeding provided that
one the recording device used doesn't
interfere with the
proceeding that the party can only
record if the proceeding is open to the
public and is not
confidential that the recording is
limited to the proceeding in which the
party is participating and that
electronic recording or transmission of
private communication of others
including bench and sidebar conferences
between Council and conferences between
Council and client are
prohibited the court has a rule
currently to allow for recording if you
fill out a for and ask for permission
the day
before as part of doing the special
Family Court committee we heard
complaints from parties regarding the
Court's recording themselves because the
court records the proceedings and there
were allegations that the recordings
were being cut off at certain parts and
so they weren't able to get the entirety
of a recording and so I think it's
important when a party is a part of a
case and perhaps they haven't thought in
Advan that they wanted to be able to
record it didn't put in the form but
something's happening that they just
didn't expect to happen a lot of times
these these parties are prosay and they
they just want to record it because they
want to remember what happened at I
think we should offer them that courtesy
and so I think in going back I know that
similar bills have been put in although
they were just to blanketly record
anything in courts and they weren't
limited to family court and it wasn't
limited to only the parties that were
part of the proceeding and I did see
that part of the push back was you know
concern about um recording private
conversations between Council
essentially and um or interfering with
the proceeding and so I did explicitly
carve out those things in here just to
try and
cover any potential issues that have
been raised
before and that's about all on this bill
I'm happy to take any questions uh to
what degree have you had conversation
with um uh judicial officials uh on this
bill so I did speak with the court about
it uh I'll let them speak to it but
their position was that they did
currently have a process for allowing
recordings of any type rather you're
part of the pro the proceeding or not to
fill out this form and as I've said I
think it's important for parties when
they're a part of the actual case it's
much different from somebody in the
audience just coming in and deciding to
record vers if you're
actually you know a party to the case
and you're going to be affected by
whatever is decided I think it's a much
different thing and I think those
parties should be able to to record
without having to fill out the form and
whatnot because sometimes parties just
don't know they need
to did the uh judicial leaders find this
to be a difficult thing on face that
they would not want this to take
place I'll let them speak to that I
think their position was just that they
had a process right now to allow for it
um but I don't think that this conflicts
with that process it just says that if
you're a party that you wouldn't have to
fill out a form in advance essentially
to do it but it does still give the
judge the leeway of of not allowing a
party to do it by saying that again it
can't be interfering with a proceeding
so if somebody's interfering with a
proceeding as part of that recording
then certainly the judge would be able
to instruct them not to do so I'm going
out on a limb and assuming that none of
the other people in the audience are
currently a judge in the court system in
the state of Hampshire am I
correct but you get getting there okay
do you wish to
testify it would be helpful rule one
pink
card any other questions of
Representative katab on the
bill thank you very much I appreciate
it
yes and the chair recognizes rep uh
former representative Betty Gabe from
Salem for three minutes on the
bill
thank you Mr chairman uh this is a long
awaited Bill I've worked on it myself on
the same subject for a few years and uh
even though the family court rules allow
recording the truth is they also
disallow and so U most people have been
told um in my experience people that
I've met who really want this bill to
pass they have been refused the right to
record and so they have to order their
own recordings which is a modest it's a
pretty modest fee to do the recording
unlike a transcript of the recording
which is extremely
expensive um and they were very
disappointed to find out that the
recording did not contain the actual
events that they were so concerned about
that put them at a great
disadvantage and uh one of one of the
people that I met could actually observe
the judge controlling the recorder
because he was standing in an open you
know an unusual place it wasn't a
regular courtroom he you could see see
his feet he turned the recorder off and
on and when you got the recording uh you
could hear funny sounds where uh the
recording was uh stopped so it's really
really critical to have accurate records
and uh this is the only way that we can
guarantee that people have an accurate
uninterrupted recording of their hearing
and I think what I anticipate was as
soon as this becomes a law that it's
okay to record your own hearing and you
respect the private parts of the
hearing that then there won't be any few
judges who um let's say edit recordings
because they'll be found out so it's not
that we expect all judges this is not an
indictment of all courtrooms but it is
pointing out the necessity of stopping
some who have a practice ractice of uh
not recording anything that they don't
want anybody else to hear which
sometimes is chastising the uh person
who's testifying will you take questions
sure your pink card said you support the
bill with amendments and I'm wondering
what that
meant
um I made a I made a mistake that I went
on another pink card I meant to say with
Amendment so okay fill that in which one
is it oh you haven't given it to me yet
okay so I'll take with amendments out
because all right any other questions of
um The Honorable Betty
gay representative McMahon thank you Mr
chairman um Miss gay specific to the
wording on on the bill before us it says
it says the judicial branch Family
Division should this not apply to all
divisions or is just the Family Division
that you would be in support of well if
someone if thank you for your question
uh if someone wanted to amend this to
make it applicable to all courtrooms I
certainly would support that but
usually usually when you're making them
a change you ask for you get the toe in
the door so right now family it's family
uh Court uh uh litigants that I have met
with who really really want this but I
wouldn't be surprised if other people uh
in other courtrooms would like it
too thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman extensive uh testimony to the
special committee on the Family Division
of the Circuit Court uh was on indeed on
the Family Division so lots of testimony
we took in uh that was related to making
one's recording the cost of getting it
if you cannot and all of that was
related specifically so this bill
addresses something that um as I look at
the co-sponsors many of us are also on
that special committee and uh so yeah
this is a incremental thing and thank
you so much I see no further questions
thank you for your testimony chair
recognizes Mr Dana
albre welcome back to
CFL good morning nice to be here uh for
the record Dana Au ntional New Hampshire
just very briefly I strongly support
this uh to be fair we should recognize
there are existing mechanisms in place
for recordings either officially
escribers or by asking the permission of
the presiding judge uh Petition of
WMUR with that I've seen very
inconsistent application depending on
which courtroom you happen to be in
across the state so I think this would
go a long way towards um providing
consistency uh and the other sort of
Biggie is the accuracy of the record on
appeal uh certainly in my own case uh
that's been an issue uh where recordings
and transcripts have sort of not lined
up and while that might be unusual it I
think it can and does happen so uh
anytime litigants have an opportunity to
sort of have a backup to what's official
I think that would go a long way to
restoring confidence in the system and
I'll leave it there thank you very much
unless you have questions
questions seeing none thank you so much
for your testimony thank you
it's the observation of the chair that
with the Judiciary um and our special
committee on Family Division of Circuit
Court uh a number of us have found the
Judiciary to be highly responsive to
concerns that we have brought in fact at
at one of our subcommittee meetings um
they started reporting on what they were
already doing that we were about to ask
them to do I mean it was that good a
relationship so irrespective of the
disposition of this bill I find that uh
what we have here will um doubtless make
some good suggestions to them with that
uh Erin krian is that attorney eron
krian and wow area code 202 the nation's
capital and you are uh what do you do in
the judicial
branch good afternoon Mr chairman I'm
the general counsel for the judicial
branch lawyers needed
lawyers a lawyer's lawyer if you will I
like that and uh what would you wish to
say to us here uh I I would first like
to thank rep kutab she is always so
thoughtful uh in all of the bills she
works on and I know that I had
opportunities to speak with her and that
she thinks out many of the contingencies
and so I I appreciate that um she put a
lot of work into this bill and my
purpose coming here is not to take a
position on it because the Judiciary
applies the laws we don't write them you
do that uh but I would like to tell you
if it's helpful to you a little bit
about our current process so that you
can maybe give us feedback if you have
it um on what you might be hearing for
example in the special committee is not
working um or is working well um as uh
Mr Albert correctly pointed out uh since
inray Petition of wur it has been the
the law of the courts that we there is a
common law right to record Court
proceedings that predates the First
Amendment it predates our state
constitution and so any person who
wishes to record a court proceeding can
do so using two processes if you're a
member of the media you register um and
you simply notify the clerk each time
you're coming to court to to record um
if you are not a member of the media you
typically complete a day pass there are
some people who record so frequently
they're just interested in the work of
the courts that they register just like
the media does but most people are only
interested in one or two cas cases
involving someone they know um and they
complete a date pass that just says this
is the my name my number and the the
proceeding I want to record uh and they
give that to the clerk that and it's
approved by the judge before they come
in and the benefit from the Court's
perspective of having these forms is
that there's very often a lot of
interest in the same cases particularly
high-profile cases and you may have so
many people who want to record that
there is not space that there have to be
pooling considerations that they're
going to displace family members of
litigant in the courtroom so there are
administrative things that the judge
likes to have this information so they
can run their courtroom um and one of
the things that we do deal with
unfortunately more than we ever did in
the past right now is um disruptive
persons in the courts we we did not have
a traditionally a very large issue with
this but more and more we do see that
there are folks that want to make a
scene in the courtroom or want to record
something for their YouTube page um this
is not your typical litigant it's not
the folks that you're meeting with who
are talking about about their own cases
it's a it's a different sort of person
that we're dealing with and so the the
courts do forbid those folks from
disruptive conduct and it says
explicitly in the guidelines to record
into the courts if you've been
disruptive in the past you may not be
permitted to record the proceeding again
uh but that is that's not common and
it's typically the the same small number
of folks uh one thing that the Supreme
Court has issued an order is although
there is a right to record proceedings
there's not typically right to record in
the common spaces of the courthouse so
you think of for example someone who's
filing a domestic violence petition a
juvenile case it's being adjudicated if
someone is just recording the lobby
areas of the Court um potentially
they're impeding on something that folks
are not uh expecting to be recorded
doing uh and so the court issued an
order that a person that was recording
outside the courtroom uh could not do so
that that's not permitted you you have
an interest in the court proceedings but
not in bothering people who are trying
to use the court facilities and and
that's typically we where we see the
most issues folks that are trying to
record people they're trying to file um
and that if someone does violate that
order we do ask them to leave the
courthouse uh so you may have heard from
folks that say I I was arrested for
recording they're not arrested for
recording they're arrested if they
refuse to stop recording and stay and
wait until the police uh come and arrest
them for trespass uh but for the most
part I I think that we find that when
litigants are interested in recording
their case it's not difficult they they
they produce this form uh they're able
to record they have a right to that the
courts have acknowledged but that there
are some Court Administration issues to
work on like a large number of people
that want to record at the same time or
a disruptive
person is there anything in this bill as
presented that would Clash with those
caveats you just mentioned so I I know
that Reb kab thought of many of these
things she she talked about
confidentiality she she discusses
disruptive conduct I think one thing
that is a general principle of
interpreting law is that we have a
relatively robust if you decide to read
it it's it's relatively long with what
row you can sit in and you can't have a
mobile equipment and you can't move your
equipment during the court proceeding
that if if the legislature passes
something subsequent is it intended to
displace that policy or is it intended
to be uh complimentary or reinforcing of
that existing policy and I think uh one
of the 10 of interpretation might be
that it's intended to displace the
existing policy and I don't know that
that's your intention but I put that
question too would counc be informed by
the opening two lines amend RSA 490d by
inserting after 490d 15 the following
new section I don't see the word replace
here I see additional language would you
agree I agree uh the only thing that I
would say is the Court's current policy
is not statutory um it it follows on
from that court case um and so it's it's
promulgated by our own rules uh so
essentially when the legislature is
speaking on area I think there'd be a
question of whether it's intended to
occupy the entire field that's currently
covered by judicial rules would it be
helpful to the bill if um an amendment
were brought that would add language to
say um in effect the
following um we are wishing to enter
into statute but not at the expense of
the Court's right to come up with its
own internal policies I think that would
certainly be clearer to us what the
intention is so that we can implement
the
intention any further questions Council
yes uh repres Vice chairman long thank
you Mr chairman uh so so back to that
the uh interfere with proceedings so I
would assume that the
judge would have authority over that and
a judge would say where your camera is
to be set up and it is to stay there is
that correct yes I I I take what um the
representative has worked on here to try
to incorporate all those concerns the
only thing I would say is the rule that
we have is just very clear you know
don't move your camera during the
proceedings don't sit too close to the
parties and so it it just gives more
guidance but I see that in principle she
has included that concern okay to follow
up on that follow up uh so displacing
that current uh what's allowed I don't
see this as this place in that because
that's what the judge could say that
stays the same correct what you think uh
it or I I hear your intention I think
there's some folks that would take
there's a there's an idea in the law of
later in time that something that's
later if it's intended to occupy the
entire field that this is the the full
guidance that it's intended to displace
an earlier um an earlier law so that is
just a question for inter that someone
would look at this and try to determine
whether that's your intention but I
think it would be helpful to them to
have you know your your statements or
any more clarity in the text about what
it is your intention to do okay I one
more question if I may you may uh so
each party uh so I'm a party uh I could
could I have my brother or sister doing
the recordings or is it I have to be
overseeing that that's a that's a good
question in terms of the interpretation
of the text of the bill I can say what's
common now is typically it is a friend
or affiliate of the litigant because
it's very difficult when you're sitting
at Council table to not accidentally
record the other party and their
consultations so you and the judge
typically does ask the recording to
occur from the gallery okay so it is
usually an affiliate of the party okay
so that would be accepted other than
myself as a l it's accepted now um I I I
don't know if someone else reading this
would say because it's each party that
it has to be that person themselves but
I see that that would potentially create
an issue that you're having to record
while you're at the table and that could
be a challenging place place to record
from good thank
you as a co-sponsor of the bill and as
chairman of the special committee I
would very much like to see this pass
but I would like it to pass in such a
way that there is minimal confusion uh
we will not be able to exec the bill
today because we do not have a quorum
and we will be going into an executive
session on the bills of today and the
non-exact bills from last week we will
be be doing that in two to three weeks
because the speaker very much wants
these bills uh because we've got 700 of
them and we have to move them through
therefore um this is up to the bill
sponsor I realize once the bill is
assigned to a committee it becomes the
committee's bill but nevertheless I give
great um leeway to the prime sponsor if
the prime sponsor is of the opinion that
a little bit of language would clarify
the possible question that might be
raised later that will be her call and
she could consult with you or indeed
anyone and if we can find acceptable
language that keeps the purpose of this
bill which I think is laudatory but
anticipates any issues that may arise
then um crank out that language um
representative kab and run it down to OS
and get it to us ahead of time so when
we exec a member of the committee can
present that um that's just what I'm
saying to just about everybody who's
been here last week and this week I like
to see things on consent anything less
than that I deem a failure so see what
we can do okay yes uh representative
McMahon thank you Mr chairman attorney
KGAN specific to the narrative in the
bill and the comments that you made
relative to common law in place uh
would would this bill then speak to not
allowing a judge to make a selective
recording I don't see that there is
language in this bill on the recordings
that occur on the court side
um so I I don't know that I can give you
an answer is is that your question or
have I misunderstood you um Mr chairman
I'll make a little with
go ahead as clear as I'd hope to be
there uh the specificity is is to allow
an individual and in this case was going
on the fact that you stated there's the
rules are there for Media or non-media
based on an application uh that they can
do that now but as we heard from a
previous uh testimony is that we had uh
judge judges on the control of the
camera on and off and uh so so so that
being said what this is stating when I
say this when I'm reading here is to
allow a party can record based on rules
I mean there's the law and then there's
the application of rules and would this
need to be more
specific than it is right now so that a
judge unilaterally in his or her Court
could not selectively determine what is
recorded after saying you may record but
I'll control what is recorded or not I'm
not aware of an instance where judge has
allowed a person to record and then has
told them that they couldn't unless they
moved into a confidential proceeding in
which case just like uh this bill it's
it's not permitted to record typically
um so I I think that that would probably
be unchanged since the bill also
acknowledges there are confidential
proceedings I don't think the current
practice would change in that regard and
uh another one follow up okay and and
and just for my clarification attorney
krian
uh who are you representing today when
you speak on the courts cuz but that's
why I asked the question earlier was
this for family court it's only or
across Municipal and Superior Etc so who
do you speak for certainly I'm the
general counsel for the courts and as
part of that job um I not only defend us
when we're sued or things of that nature
I also come to speak with the
legislature when you have questions for
us um we do not typically take positions
so I I wouldn't want you to to read me
as doing that but we do like to be able
to answer questions in case it's helpful
to you um so i' I've come on behalf of
the judicial branch to answer your
questions and and that means that's
across all divisions that you speak for
that's correct although I should say
that I almost always have to confer with
someone else to make sure I'm getting
you the best most accurate information I
would not want anyone to think that I
can answer any question of New Hampshire
law because I would have to research
them before I do but yes I I can appear
on any subject and and my last last one
Mr chair as the chair pointed out you
have an area code that's not 63 uh does
that imply you don't live here I live uh
in Northfields I went to college at
Georgetown 20 years ago another quality
decision okay what I want to make sure
that you're local so we can have access
to your expertise of course but I I do
want to be fair with you I did I I did
work with the federal government for
some years I went down to DC after 911
to be a federal terrorism prosecutor and
I I now can report that I have solved
that problem for you you're welcome
thank you uh I'm only kidding uh but I'm
now back in New Hampshire where my
family lives so that is that is why I
have a 202 area code well just for
record it's not it's not my problem you
know what I'm saying I I want to make
sure that where you were is that you're
accessible and then your guidance would
be recognized immediately of course I'm
a I'm a state employee for the judicial
branch thank you very much are you
familiar of course you are with the
Chevron deference and are you familiar
that what we're hearing from that
because I've been tracing this one for
years is that therefore it would be much
better when the leg legislature speaks
for the legislature to speak
distinctly because otherwise the
bureaucracy interprets and Chevron is
narrowing that so therefore it is
incumbent on the bills we file the laws
we seek to pass that we say what we mean
and we mean what we say so that the
there is minimal second guessing would
you agree yes there's there's no doubt
that everyone in the courts that the
clearer it can be the easier it is
because we want to implement what you
intended we don't want to accidentally
do something other than your policy
intention thank you very
much uh except for rep representative
bigford whom I overlooked sorry uh thank
you Mr chairman thank you um I'm trying
to Envision how this works in the
courtroom um I I assume people often
show up for court before the judge comes
out of Chambers so are they going to
have a sign up that says okay you can
record this session and then the judge
would say okay not anymore we're going
to be confidential like we would at a
slackman meeting say but how ahead of
time how would they know uh how do you
envision that the public would just be
told at the beginning of
proceedings I think it's typically when
different cases might be called in the
same so one might be confidential case
and one might not be yeah oh I'm sorry
not speaking into the microphone um but
what typically someone does is it's a
onepage form called the day pass and you
just put your name contact information
in the case that you want to record and
you bring it to the clerk's office and
they will know how many people are
requesting to cord particularly if they
have a numbers problem so you can
imagine for a very high profile case a
lot of different folks might want to
record who may not be members of the
media which is perfectly acceptable and
then there's an issue of making sure
that there's space for everyone wants to
record particularly if there's big bulky
equipment that they want to use and you
don't want them to be disruptive to the
proceedings so typically folks put it on
that day pass and it's all handed to the
clerk who then lets them know yep
there's room for you no problem um you
can come on in um or if there's some
sort of issue uh that they can't but
it's that's I would say that's
relatively rare um because usually when
there's a case that has that much
attention a high-profile case the media
pools they they agree to use each
other's footage um so it's it's
relatively um uncommon to have an issue
arranging pool footage with members of
the media it's you trailing off for me
my hearing is not that good um usually
when we have a high-profile case and a
lot of media Outlets want to record at
once they pull their coverage so that
they are using one camera feed um so
usually we're able to accommodate that
even if we have so many requests for
coverage that there's not enough space
do you one more do you have um how much
in advance do they need to uh day slip
you day something day pass it's it's
usually the same day it's it's almost
always immediately before the proceeding
oh okay thank
you thank you for your testimony and
with that I conclude the hearing on
House Bill
1266 as I said we cannot execute today
for lacking of a quorum and if
representative katab and you wish to
meet you have that right and if not you
have that right
too and with that we now move we I open
the hearing to House Bill
1263 relative to Parenting Co
coordinators in high conflict cases and
um she needs no introduction but I I'm
going to give her one anyway
representative Caitlyn
cab thank you Mr chairman and honorable
members of the child and family law
committee again for the record my name
is representative kitn cab and I
represent the town of Windham Rockingham
17 I'm here today to
introduce this bill relative to
Parenting
coordinators I want to note
that when the family court was first
introduced back in 2004 as part of the
family law task force that was chaired
by judge Nina
Gardner she recommended
as one of not many recommendations she
had highly recommended implementing
a a parenting coordinator and this model
is currently used in 15 other states at
least um when we got a summary from ncsl
they included some of the states that
it's used in although it was not
inclusive of all including Massachusetts
New Jersey and
Vermont and so it was modeled off of
some other some some legislation from
some other states I took pieces that
kind of made sense from from uh some
some pieces and and took some from
another so it was my goal to kind
of make it as simplistic as possible
while covering all the pertinent areas
and the the purpose of doing this is
really that in these high conflict
cases when parties each have an attorney
and they're paying quite a bit of money
for these attorneys and these cases are
going on quite a bit of time the
attorneys are kind of each arguing what
each party thinks but nobody's really
getting these parties together to try
and say is there anywhere we can come
and find a happy medium on this and as
we know when judges decide these things
judges don't know anything about our
family they don't know what what hours
that we work or what our kids
extracurricular activities are and and
how a schedule that they may put put in
place may affect this family and rather
it's going to be in the best interest of
the children and so I truly believe that
if we could get these parents together
with a trained person who is is trained
in in either psychology or um social
work that can kind of get these parties
to make some progress and come to a
possible agreement that may best work
for their family that that would be
ideal and and certainly much
more financially feasible for many of
these families to do so because it would
be at a a much you know lower rate so
that was really my my goal with this and
this would be that both parties would
have to agree in order for the parenting
coordinator
to be ordered by a judge both parties
would have to agree to it and in order
for any report to go to the judge both
parties would also have to agree on that
and the reason for that was I talked to
several family law attorneys who told me
that
currently most of the family law
attorneys will recommend to their
clients not to use a g because the gal
comes up with a report and it it's going
to the judge and the parties can't say
oh no we don't want this report we don't
you know we don't want to send this
report maybe they don't agree to it and
they can say that they don't agree with
it but they can't there's nothing that
can be kind of done to undo that and so
with that in mind they typically
recommend not to use a
g
and with this if they were going to
recommend to their clients to use it and
that they wouldn't need to be have an
attorney present in order to be meeting
with the parenting coordinator in good
faith here they'd want to know that
unless the parties had agreed agreed to
the the final outcome that this wasn't
going to be used against them and so
that's that's really where this was kind
of modeled from and I am happy to take
any
questions representative McMahon thank
you Mr chairman representative kutab um
just relative to the line four on the
bill uh where it says the court May
appoint and then then it subsequently
says upon multiple agreements wouldn't
uh why would you not consider the court
shall appoint because it still is
mitigated on the agreement of the
parties
involved
um perhap so the reason why is
that one of the concerns when I was
putting this in was uh related to
domestic violence and I didn't want to
exclude domestic violence survivors from
being able to use this tool if they
wanted to use this tool and so that's
why I didn't explicitly put that in here
but I did state that they would have to
agree to it and I also said May because
maybe a judge really just thinks it it's
not in the best interest of these
parties because of something else that's
going on and so I didn't want to make it
a obligatory thing one
followup U uh the followup is relative
to the guardian or Guardian NL GL gal
not being preferred would would that not
give the Avenue that it still will be
the preferred methodology for a G versus
a
professional
uh parenting coordinator to be to be
determined the the May versus
shell So currently G's aren't ordered
unless the parties are agreeing because
the parties have to pay for them so I
would think that in my discussions with
family law attorneys they would much
prefer this because it's again if the
parties are agreeing on a final outcome
of how what they want to do with a
parenting plan then it's going to the
court versus the g even if the parties
don't agree there's a report that's
going to the court and so with that
there's a lot
of holding back perhaps or not fully
going all in because you're you're
you're talking in a reserved manner
because you know that these things could
potentially be used against you with a G
Al verse you know that's not going to
happen with a parenting
coordinator okay thank you very much
thank you Mr chairman anyone
else representative Bickford thank you
Mr chairman thank you um down on line
25 at the end of it it says if a party
objects to the appointment the court
shall appoint a different person or
confirm the appointment within seven
days after the date of the party's
objection so does that Force somebody
into it uh the way I read it anyway
I so this is requiring that the parent
ing coordinator shall disclose to each
of the parties if there's
any potential conflict of
interest and if there is one then it's
offering the party um seven days
to object to that
and
I
if I may yeah yeah I'm hung up on the
the court shall appoint a different
person or confirm is that what you're
looking at too yeah yeah okay I'm happy
to look at that language further with
you afterwards okay and if I may but
that's if the parties if the court
chooses to appoint somebody in the first
place yeah go ahead okay we'll get back
to that
um uh um there's also collaborative law
and there's also mediators and so where
do you see this fitting in amongst that
those things that I recall and
congratulations for going back to 2004
20 years ago and looking at the family
law task
force thank you for that question
uh so I
think it really depends on the mediator
that you're getting but a lot of what's
been been presented is that
mediators the court appointed mediators
are are kind of Messengers and they're
kind of going back and forth but they're
not really suggesting and they're not
trained
to try and help help the parties to
reach a happy medium and I think the
other thing you're referring to is
neutral case evaluation which is again
another tool where you know a judge kind
of says well if this were to come before
me then potentially I would rule this
way and so do you think we could come in
the middle but I think this would just
be yet another tool that you could use
without having
to
um get to the point where you could even
get neutral case evaluation ordered I
guess so I think it's just another tool
in the toolbox and it wouldn't be
something that would be used unless the
parties were wanting to use it okay and
one further thing I may thank you Mr
chairman um The Guardian lium uh has a
board that polies them this does I don't
see anything in here that would keep
them on track from deviating or getting
off track like we've seen other
complaints about other parties um I
don't I I don't know what to say about
that I guess I did you have any thought
you could share with me so I was trying
not to make this too yeah difficult to
implement it I am requiring that they
hold a current New Hampshire license in
their in the parenting coordinator's
area of practice so they would have to
be a licensed practitioner of some sort
meeting these requirements but I was
trying not to create kind of another
oversight board for yet another thing
and another thing that somebody would
have to pay a fee for to apply to and
and all of that so I'm leaving it at the
discretion of the court on how to best
implement it
um I think
that
however they best see fit to implement
it I'm okay with okay thank
you any other questions uh represent
Vice chairman
L thank you Mr chairman uh actually back
to
four uh starting 20
to 28 uh first line
I the appointed parenting coordinator
shall disclose to each party the
attorney the attorneys of
record and the courts familial Financial
uh Dennis says on 23 uh that they've had
with the child either party the
attorneys of
record that's not a duplicate correct
that's you got to disclose to the
attorneys of record of any relation you
have uh including with those the
attorneys of record correct because
there has
been parties that have mentioned in the
past what they proce ceed to be a
conflict of interest
because the other attorney perhaps had a
relationship with the G or in the law
fir of some sort so I just want it to be
abundantly clear if there's any conflict
of interest in any way it's got to be
disclosed okay and a follow up follow up
yeah thank you uh so what I'm thinking
is you know after a lot of these
hearings and hearing these
complaints it seems to me that the
attorneys of record um um would be
problematic because the parents are
choosing so if I'm a litigant and
there's a relation in my relation was I
happen to be on another
case uh you know with with the attorney
a record uh but has a parent I'm
thinking yeah no I don't want this
person uh do do you see I you know I'm
trying to um I'm trying to minimize
because familiarity isn't you know a a
uh you know a
um social relation it could also be a
professional relation which attorneys
must have a lot of that uh so I'm I'm
wondering if do you believe that there
would be uh it would be problematic
getting these uh uh brto
coordinators
um because of uh if we could detailed
more of the attorneys of record if it's
professional
is that an issue that we need to know um
I mean it's a familiarity but it's not a
social one it's not a
uh you understand what I'm trying to get
at I'm trying to make it easier for the
litigants to agree for this
coordinator uh and if I find out that
this coordinator had a relation with my
ex's attorney and it was just um I mean
it doesn't doesn't say you have to say
what it was well well actually it does I
think right I you know if it's if it was
just a professional thing it wouldn't
bother me it's a professional thing you
you run into your profession all the
time uh but if it was a social thing
that would be
different thank you for that question so
yeah so that this does explicitly say
familial Financial or social
relationship so if the professional
relationship was Financial in that you'd
been a partner at a law firm together
and you were financially benefiting then
that would need to be disclose but if it
was strictly a professional relationship
where you've seen this person before
because I mean a lot of these
professionals do eventually cross
circles and know each other I don't
think that simply knowing somebody is a
conflict and that might be a little bit
cumbersome to have to disclose all of
that but I think it's very important to
disclose any sort of uh Financial or
social relationship or and and most
definitely if you're related by family
okay so familiar isn't uh
uh I worked on a group at the
bar uh at the bar association with this
lawyer so familial was was intended to
mean that it was a family member um okay
yeah so I can just double check that
definition there um that was used in a
few different State statues but I can
just check that we have a definition of
familial somewhere in ours okay thank
you anyone
else thank you representative
thank you we do have another bill and
another one following that and the
weather is still not very nice and I
have a stack of cards uh the chair is
given discretion to limit the amount of
time a person can speak we were also
exhorted at chairman and vice Chairman's
meeting this morning to say if you are
called upon a little further down the
stack of cards and what you have to
present to us us is pretty much what we
just
heard the chairman has the right to say
thank you say it in one
sentence and that is for the good order
of all the hearings we have so with that
in mind I'm going to give um the
remaining uh speakers uh three and a
half minutes and I've got to watch and
at 3 minutes I'll hold up my hand or
wave which means you wrap it up in a
half a minute
and one person has been very very um
exceptional on this is Mr tangu you have
been the time management Rockstar so
I've got a pink card from you and if you
would like to come up three minutes once
you turn on the
mic thank you chairman Parson um I
wanted to uh just start out um uh with
discussing uh the previous bill that I
was listening to um I am in support of
the that will take out of the minutes
here if you wish go ahead um for the
recording in the court I do agree with
that um however there's an amendment
that I will suggest and I know that
you're um not able to exec these right
now um but the restrictive language
article 8 says that the government shall
be held accountable and that allows in
my opinion uh for us to record in the
courts um and so
therefore I ask that you guys remove
from the
bill um anything that restricts anyone
from recording uh you can record the
court can restrict what you um publish
so even if something's private um now to
this bill I am in support of this bill
um I think it's a great Bill there was a
lot of care that was put into it
um for one thing that uh the parties get
to decide at the front end to use the
court services and then on the back end
before anything's submitted they're able
to decide whether or not to do that um
there is one thing that I am concerned
with though however um and that is the
requirements to become
a uh appointee uh to help out I think
that that is restrictive I think that we
do need some more people who might be
interested in family law and families um
that AR in the Echo chamber of the uh
legal uh construct um and and those
requirements to have I I agree with the
requirements to have training however
the requirements to have a specific
education I have a GED I'm articulate
I'm well read I can understand these
laws and um I think that will alleviate
and bring some other people in providing
that they do go through the training and
um with that being said uh I'm I'm all
set if there's any questions I'd be
happy to answer
them two minutes and 20 seconds bam you
are on a roll any questions for Mr
tangue nope seeing none thank you so
much chair now calls upon uh The
Honorable Betty gay you support the bill
and this is where we put in with
amendments and um three and a half
minutes thank you Mr
chairman I have I have a few
questions um my first my first statement
is I really like the this bill it has
wonderful parental Choice built into it
sections 1 2 3
uh six really spell it out I have a
couple of concerns and I may have a may
have a solution for the confusion on
lines 26 and 27 about if it's talking
about the appointed par parenting
coordinator who might have a conflict of
interest a conflict of interest so
online's 20 um four a party shall have
seven days from the date of the
disclosures to object to the appointment
ointment based upon information if a
party objects to the appointment the
court shall appoint a different person I
would put a period there and then if no
objection is filed then the judge would
confirm the appointment within seven
days if that's the intent of the
authors um my
concerns so that's a that's not really a
serious concern on mine except if you
really mean that if somebody objects 7
Days Later the judge could simply say
that's tough you're getting them so I
would like you know that is one of my
concerns that I'd like to get fixed um I
have a question about using a parental a
parenting coordinator which sounds
really good does this mean somebody
could be forced to have a
gal I've talked with people who thought
they had no choice and they had to have
a g and once they had one they couldn't
get rid of it and then I've heard other
people talk about a g being uh an
option so I would really prefer to make
sure the wording allowed that people did
not have to have a gal they could choose
a parenting
coordinator
um let's
see one of my real serious concerns is
in seven Roman numeral 7 page number 11
on page
two a parenting coordinator appointed by
the court shall be immune from civil
liability in any claim for injury family
court and that's where I'm coming from
is family court has lots of people who
are immune and no matter what awful
thing happens the the litigant is pretty
much
stuck um
if they get a decree that cites things
that are not that are factually
inaccurate they cannot even appeal based
on factual inaccuracy so I'm very
concerned how somebody else like a g
too somebody else being
granted immunity from civil
liability I
think oh ran roll five how many seconds
do I have you have half a minute okay
I'm I'm concerned about the fees and
costs in Roman five they shall be paid
by the parties equally and if we really
do divorces and split down uh monetary
values in the middle then they'd be
equal unless the court enters an order
directing otherwise again if the person
parenting coordinator can recommend one
person pay more based on their party's
failure failure to work in good faith it
could just be that the parenting
coordinator has had it with them and
they're getting even so that that's my
concern that I don't think I really like
Roman numeral 5 either thank you so much
any questions for the former
representative
gay thank you seeing none thank you so
much and the chair now recognizes for
three and a half minutes uh Tim
I'm sorry sir T I'm
sorry
all thank chairman Parson I am a a
victim of um high
conflict divorce situation that requires
a significant amount of interaction with
a court we can divorce for 10 years and
she has been held in contempt six times
that has been arrested for I am
experiencing B there are I I while I
wholeheartedly support this bill the
issue at hand is the effectiveness of
the parenting coordinator because I we
have worked with parenting coordinators
in my experience that have a I'll use a
psych psych psychology background and
they are they do not want to put in hard
decisions hard requirements
for the parents to
enact typically and we have found is
that a parenting coordinator with a
legal background will come in and make a
decision enforcing an action that is
required so while I support the bill the
the lack of Effectiveness the lack of
ability to make changes the lack of
ability to hold yes sir the mic front I
have it on it's
not now it is on apologies do I need to
restate I car myself well all picked up
from thank you so my concern is that the
the parenting coordinator does not have
the authority if not granted
specifically by the judge in order to
make change in effect in effect we'll
call it a penalty if one parent overacts
one parent does not comply with an order
one parent does not do what's in the
best interest of the children if you're
just there and they try to affect a
mediate mediated solution and one parent
is not open to doing that then it
creates a situation where the parenting
coordinator has their hands tied and
can't do anything so a parents could be
spending money and one parent just
doesn't agree therefore doesn't affect
any no changes made and it's a waste of
money that's been my experience I worked
with Dr Garber down in down in nashwa
and he wasn't able to affect
change any questions for the witness
thank you for yes go ahead repres uh
chairman Vice thank you Mr chairman so
so in your experience with 10 years you
have had a coordinator parenting have
you had a parenting coordinator had
three coordinators okay right Dr Garber
being one of them uh another lawyer
being another one and then another
lawyer being another one the issue
became you know the my ex-wife's ability
to pay therefore I was funding all of it
and there was no
let's say ability to enforce a decision
okay and follow up with me uh I mean I I
respect your opinion with this next
question is um do you do you do you
sense that you and your ex would have
agreed with a parenting
coordinator initially we agreed with
bringing on Dr Garber and then Dr Garber
in the psych in psychological profile
side the psychologist side at Dr Garber
you know we both agreed you know in
front of him to certain solutions for
our children and then she just stopped
following them right and that was and
then Dr Garber was like okay you did
this you there's no penalty to my
ex-wife for not following what was
agreed upon yeah but with respect to
this bill uh both parties have to agree
do do you see a complication with that I
do I do because if both parties can
agree and it can be a great relationship
and great thing but if the one of the
parties violates the agreement that is
you know that you talk about in in
working with a coordinator there's no
ability to enforce unless you go back to
the court file a motion and do that
right uh follow up I may follow
articulate this better yeah what I'm
meaning is that both parties have to
agree to the parenting coordinator yes
do do you see complications with that
like in your case would you I you think
you could agree I know you agreed with
one you had three I think you said
that's
correct I we agreed to a coordinator
right that was fine okay that that was
established okay in the me in in the
sessions with the coordinator with Dr
Garber there was agreement on how to
approach certain challenges with
different different kids and then she
just violated that agreement that's what
I'm referring to but as far as agreeing
to the coordinators that's that's okay
okay great thank you you representative
bigford thank you Mr chairman thank you
um if you're already using a parent
coordinator uh why do we need a bill for
parenting coordinator is there something
special in the bill
bill my my view on the parenting
coordinator holistically generally is
correct that there is a need for it
right such that people have are made a
made aware of it not everybody is made
aware of it we were made aware of it
divorce proceedings that that's
absolutely necessary there is a
codification of of the need for a
parenting Bill parenting coordinator is
that and the judge can bring it up and
the judge can can do that I fully
support that and my point here
representative Bickford is that there
needs to be the ability for the the
coordinator to affect
change am I answering your question I
don't look like I am not the way I
expected okay can you restate your
question please um well if we already
have if I may paring coordinators out
there because I thought I heard that
this is something new um then why do we
need a piece of legislation that doesn't
really do any policing or any uh
enforcement or any anything the judge
can already do it apparently according
to what I think I hearing from you there
are parenting coordinators in this state
that are effective and there are
parenting coordinators in this state
that are ineffective and there are
parenting coordinators that don't have
any training they call themselves
parenting
coordinators but if I made the judges a
signing parting coordinators in in my
situation the first one with Dr Garber
was mutually agreed upon did the judge
get involved at all and say yes I agree
you can have that yes and we took an or
the the parenting coordin required us to
have an order from the court assigning
him as a parenting coordinator
okay thank you that's good thank you
thank you thank you for your testimony
yes sir chair would like to call back
representative katab to answer that
question because you filed the bill I
know I'm a co-sponsor but if we have
parental co parenting coordinators in
the state what does this bill add
yes thank you for the question so in my
discussions with the court it was
actually a
an idea from them to explore this they
thought that it would be helpful at one
point um and I don't think that perhaps
all the judges are even aware that maybe
that there are some that are privately
doing it
however I'm not sure that something
exists right now for the judges to
actually order one to be used I could
see
if the parties are if they're told like
hey you can do this if you want to do
this but I don't think there's anything
right now
that's permissive for the judges to
currently order them but I'll let the
this gentl has had three of
them well he was told that he could have
them but he didn't state that he was
ordered to do so by the court or
anything the court just one of the
judges made him aware that he could do
it the bill before us does not order it
either well it's permissive that they
are able to order it right but it's not
I don't I'm not sure that they're
currently able to do so okay uh to your
knowledge um are there presently
academic or professional qualifications
in place that this bill now adds not to
my knowledge uh to your knowledge um in
the uh coordinators presently serving is
there 24 hours of training in fields or
does this bill add it to your knowledge
this bill adds that and to my knowledge
there wouldn't be something exempting
a report going to the court unless both
parties agree without this bill and I
think that's a big pause that I heard
from several Family Court attorneys that
I spoke with that they wouldn't advise
their clients to use one
unless that unless both parties had
agreed that the report would be going
into the into the court because they
wouldn't
want something to go forward that one
party likes and the other party doesn't
like is there anything else in this bill
that I haven't thought of that this bill
may be adding to what presently
exists well also there's the requirement
for the disclosure if there is a
conflict of interest which I know that
that's been something that's come up
many times in in regards to the gal
thing I know that there was an issue
that the judicial conduct commission had
gotten involved with with the judge who
had appointed a g that was
uh that had a so very much so a social
relationship with her family uh so this
would also protect for that so I think
that there's several things in here
that would be provided that are not
currently provided for good I think that
answers representative Bickford's
question thank you for the clarification
thank you uh while you're here while
you're here W sherff yeah uh Vice
chairman long uh thank you Mr chairman
so representative uh I I just need to
clarify my understanding was in the uh
in the Family Court committee
there were high conflict um there were
apparently coordinators were high
conflict my understanding that it wasn't
on all the high conflicts it was the the
six seven eight nine 10 years uh and
there were a shortage of them they
weren't appointing them
to um you know an immediate conflict uh
case is that your understanding that
that's sort of what I got out of the
need for
this so I think what you're referring to
is the high conflict docket which not
everybody's referred there but that's
not that doesn't have a parenting
coordinator that was just specific
judges that had been assigned to this
high conflict docket that could take
more time with these cases to
to get more in depth with them so so on
that list would this uh would parenting
coordinators be an
option so that that's something separate
that's just a high conflict docket where
you're assigned to a specific Judge
who take who takes these high conflict
cases and and is more indepth with them
and has more time set aside for those
cases okay yeah my this is a completely
different tool it would be separate okay
so so um so parenting coordinators
couldn't be assigned
to that list I mean even though it's a
fresh conflict uh you know it's it's
it's a fresh case uh I I mean I just
just recall in the conversations with uh
this family uh Court committee uh we
thought this was a good idea but it
wasn't being used enough and I don't
know why it wasn't being used I thought
maybe it wasn't allowed or and that's
why this bill was necessary to uh you
know I thought it was a good idea to
have these coordinators that would be
helpful uh and that's where I'm thinking
that this bill would help that yeah I
agree with you I think it would help and
I think perhaps attorney krian might
have some more of the Court history than
I have um with regard to the usage of
them but they could absolutely be used
in addition to being on the high
conflict docket okay thank you thank you
thank you and the last to testify is Mr
Dana
Al three and a half
minutes thank you Mr chair again Dana
alre uh Nash New Hampshire I strongly
support this bill uh just to Echo uh
some of the things we heard earlier uh
first and foremost it is definitely
another tool in the Box I think it's a
very valuable
tool uh second uh I'd urge you to
consider this uh as a very useful tool
in combination with the bill that's
coming up
next uh House Bill
10006 uh is sort of addressing two two
different ways to address a very serious
problem which is how do you get parents
to follow a parenting plan if they're
struggling to do that and I Echo very
strongly what Mr Penis said earlier I'm
facing have faced those issues myself uh
in terms of of whether we need this uh I
would respectfully argue the primary
problem is that we haven't had it for
the past seven years and that I haven't
been able to take advantage of this at
statute
um the the issue is as you put it say
what you mean mean what you
say this puts everything in on what the
qualifications are uh what the rights
and responsibilities of the part are it
sort of gets the wild west out of it
where you know Mr penk went through
three and I didn't have an opportunity
for any and I sure would have liked
that
um just uh one other technical point to
follow up on what the honorable Betty
gay said on immunity so this is page
two uh lines 11 and 12 I would would
respectfully suggest the word shall be
immune from civil
liability be amended shall be afforded
qualified
immunity could you speak to
that uh yes so the sort of two extremes
we want to
avoid uh are on the one hand where
somebody in this position has gone
really off the rails
and nobody has any recourse and I think
that's kind of already in here is
willful and won and I've had my
experiences where I felt that I've not
had
recourse for because of immunity issues
the flip side of that coin is you don't
want a wild west where anybody can get
sued for just about anything because
then nobody wants to take the
job and we need
lots of people who want to take this job
we could use a lot of these people doing
a good job and so I think qualified
immunity strikes a happy medium and it
also again nails down to say what you
mean and mean what you say for the rest
of the language in the bill will you
take questions yes any questions from Mr
albre seeing none thank you so much and
this closes the hearing
on what thank you oh you're welcome
house
12163 and let's take about 30 seconds to
arrange our paper
clips and once again we cannot exec the
bill today because we lack a quorum we
will do it in two or three weeks um and
uh there is no mandate for any amendment
to this bill bill but it's possible and
if so make sure it gets done in advance
so we can see it just before our exec
session and it will be then presented by
a member of this
committee and now I open the hearing on
House Bill
106 relative to creating a family access
motion for the enforcement of parenting
plans Prime sponsor representative katab
please come on
up thank you Mr chairman and honorable
members of the child and family law
committee I'm representative Caitlyn cab
representing Windam Rockingham District
17 the reason for this family access
motion Bell is that we currently have on
the books
461a 4 which is a contempt motion and
the way that that statute is written
it requires that a Content motion be
reviewed and I put an emphasis on the
word reviewed by the court within 30
days and so what that means is just that
they need to to take a look at it it
doesn't mean that they need to take any
action it does not mean that they need
to call a
hearing and
there have been some cases where it
took multiple years before a hearing was
actually held on these and so I think at
the end of the day when we have some of
these high conflict
cases and there's finally some sort of
an agreement reached we have or there's
been one that's court ordered we have a
parenting plan in place and then one
parent is not following the parenting
plan there's not a whole lot that the
parents can do because
the police will tell you well you have
to go back to court and then if you file
the contemp motion the court doesn't
always hear it very very timely and so
this was modeled off a legislation out
of
Missouri
and when they implemented this they
actually
had a decrease in some of the conflicts
because it was enough to kind of scare
the other party that wow there can
actually be these consequences if I'm
not following the parenting plan and and
I do want to say that there is an
emphasis in section 4 that it's really
the visitation piece that we're giving
these these punishments out for so this
isn't you know the the parent is
um not sending Suzie in in the clothes
that that the other parent wanted them
to come home in or whatnot this is you
know you're not following the visitation
that you should be and you're
withholding that the child from the
other parent and I think there's been an
increase in in many states with these
with with with this being an issue and
we want to be on top of this and address
this and and ensure that parents aren't
missing out on that important time as
their kids are growing up so that's what
this seeks to
do
questions
anyone representative Bickford thank you
Mr chair thank you again um
okay um on line
five and I see it again on line 16 and
18 and they used the uh term uh
visitation which New Hampshire we don't
use that anymore we use parenting time
and uh parting
time um so I I think it would be
important to to change that to New
Hampshire language and you'll find that
in the family law task force but
thank you for the question
recommendation I appreciate that and I
am happy to amend to State parenting
time in there instead of uh visitation
super while you're up do you see any
other places where the language should
be brought better into
conform uh is there more it's lines 15
and 16 and I will take care of that okay
that's the only thing I caught Mike 18
as well okay
and representative
L I did well you get back to me do you
want me to go ahead or anybody still has
a question well we still we on the
specific thing of language changes while
we remember it then we'll come back to
you
okay you thought you line
28 line line 28 is uh enforced
visitation rights thank you and I'll
remove the custody part as well just to
say parenting time instead of
custody or visitation good job eagle
eyes uh representative Bickford you may
proceed uh with your question chairman
and thank you again um there's another
statute I I think I'm G to guess it at
633 co4 I think um but it's about
interference with custody or
interference with parenting uh time and
a lot of people have spoke to it and
said hey how come the police don't go
and get them that's a crime and it
actually is a crime in that uh statute I
don't know if you're familiar with it or
not you are okay well some of the
problems I've
seen is people will complain and say you
know she or he has not you know get the
children to me when they should and uh
that should be a crime and so I go like
well how late are they well 15 minutes
later that's my time and I go like
that's kind of petty and uh so I I've
always wondered well what would be
reasonable for the col off point and say
yeah it's interference it would be
criminal and what should go down this
line or down this Lane here might call
it any thoughts on that thank you for
the question so I think with the
interference statue I think it also
involves like removing the child out of
the state for the purpose of withholding
them from the other parent essentially
during their parenting time is what I
think stronger penalty there yeah I
think that kind of is what it talks to
but you know I didn't when I when I read
through when this was implemented in
Missouri and and this was many years ago
that was implemented in Missouri I I
think it was almost 20 years ago um I
have the number in my notes but um one
of the things that they had mentioned in
there was that they didn't want to
mention a specific number of minutes or
something that a party was late because
what they didn't want was to create
another problem where somebody said oh
well this statute only applies if I'm
more than a half an hour late so I'm
going to be 29 minutes late dropping off
the kids every time cuz that's certainly
not you're not acting in good faith and
I think in that point if somebody is
habitually always dropping their kids
off 20 29 minutes late that would be
more reasonable right this is giving the
judges the discretion here and to decide
what is or isn't reasonable and I'm not
sure that we should Define that I would
hope that a party is not going to file
something like that and if if if they do
then they're paying a filing fee you
know to to go ahead and file that so I
would hope that it would be for good
cause okay thank you
any other
questions representative long thank you
Mr chairman uh yeah just more clarity on
uh parenting time uh what you're saying
is the actual parenting time uh so um
like in the parenting plan I pick up the
child when I'm getting the visits they
pick up the child when it's time for
them uh that that's not what you're
looking
for no so this was more to be just
towards the the visitation time because
I think that's really what I I think
that there
is there is a contemp motion that is
available if there's other areas that
are being broken and perhaps less of a
hey we need to hurry up and have this
because you
know I uh actually saw a video on on Tik
Tok two nights ago where a judge had
ordered that basically a a a parent had
violated a DV order and so because of
that the mom withheld the child from the
father and by the time the order was
actually heard it wasn't until January
and so at that point between September
and January much parenting time had been
dismissed and the the the judge said
well I understand but I didn't change
your your parenting order as part of
that DV violation so you still violated
that so now you need to give him the kid
for 67 days straight and so I think
we've got
to make make sure that we're
not waiting such exorian amounts of time
that it's a it could be putting somebody
in danger and I think there's a lot of
discretion and to if an emergency
experte hearing is going to be issued
right but I think also we've got to keep
in mind that if it is over a year at
that point that one parent kept the
child from the other parent that parents
missed all that time and that child if
they're young they're going to be
uncomfortable probably going to that
other parents house they've they've
experienced alienation at that point so
a lot really at stake and that was why I
think it's important that these issues
are addressed quickly and timely yeah
especially for the the visitation piece
vers some of the other pieces may not be
as important to quickly address right
thank
you sing No Hands Up thank you so much
for your testimony and the chair
recognizes Dana albrech who
has already wted our appetite on this
one
thank you Mr chair again Dana alre uh
this bill is desperately needed if there
was a single Bill other than perhaps the
Shared Parenting that we could get past
this would be it uh in my
opinion uh I am one of these cases I saw
my oldest son last night because he
lives with
me uh I've seen my younger children
perhaps a grand total of 30 40 days
total uh over the past 7 years and
that's not because that's what the
parenting plan said it gave me
substantially more time it simply wasn't
followed uh also in my specific
case uh I've had a contempt motion filed
I'm going to say November 1st
2019 uh no hearing was ever held on that
to get even an order on it took several
years and on appeal to the New Hampshire
state supreme court to construe the
existing
statute uh they said that was
essentially okay because of the way the
existing statute was written which says
to me you really need to amend the
statute
um
just to
Echo um replica tab
when the the real need for timeliness
here is and then when you go too long
without following the plan then you
start getting all these other
issues like uh pick your name
estrangement alienation but kids just
let's just say kids aren't are used to
only seeing one parent without laying
blame and that creates even more
problems
and right now
without going into the details of some
of the other case types I think some
other case types in the court system are
getting much higher priority at the
expense of
this and kids need their parents if
there's not a really good
reason for them not to be with them and
to
allow a child to go years without seeing
a parent because it's not a priority on
the court docket is just wrong it needs
to be the highest priority on the court
stocket that's all I have to say thank
you I'm trusting with the seven new
judges being being appointed and it
looks like we may be getting seven or
more in the next budget I'm hoping some
of these backlogs will go away but I
agree with you yeah any questions for uh
Mr
albrech and thank you very much and
thank you when you uh gave testimony to
the special committee as
well
welcome and next the chair
recognizes well here we go again I can
read the ZIP code uh Mr Atkinson would
you please come forward counselor and
help me get the name and I apologize
sorry it's um my name is Jame marel and
Jame Mark Cal yes my handwriting is God
awful and I I I apologize for it that's
all right but you do zip codes great
yeah that's zip code is correct yeah um
I first as an opening statement I'll
I'll try to be brief I certainly
recognize the a the agony that parent
that that parental disputes create I'm
certainly sensitive to what was said
before about the need for appropriate
enforcement of parenting plans the one
thing is is that when I look at the
proposals in this statute a lot of them
already exist and simply need
enforcement uh you have broad broad
remedies do already exist in the system
um RSA
461a uh deals uh basically with
modifications of parenting plans and it
also uh has a couple of flaws in it but
I'm getting a little ahead of myself
because what we have is actually can be
addressed in an upcoming coming bill
that's been proposed on contempt and
with just a few amendments you can
really put some teeth into parenting
plans uh I'm thinking of
um and I really don't want to get ahead
of myself but um probably have to on
um House Bill 1192 FN which the
committee May address in its discretion
at some future time dealing with
contempt
I don't know when it's slated to be
heard I don't either yeah and I know
that I'm not supposed to be addressing
bills that are presently not in front of
the committee so um just a couple of
concerns here number one is is that it
really doesn't this would be difficult
to plead effectively because it doesn't
Define what what a contempt is uh
basically contempts are in the state of
New Hampshire contempts are defined
basically as willful and intentional
Disobedience to a statute um New
Hampshire case law stands for the
proposition that uh it's going to be a
willful Disobedience to a valid court
order and I think we can add unequivocal
comp coupled with an ability to comply
with a court order so we don't have a
mechanism for the way courts are going
to plead these cases uh willful
Disobedience as I said voluntary and
intentional not act
accidental um the other thing is you
don't really show what the standard of
proof is going to be to be able to show
somebody is in contempt generally
speaking the standard is uh
preponderance of the evidence however
when I look at some of the protocols for
parenting and things like that looking
at Family Court protocol rules which are
considered best practices but not Bing
on the court you look and you find
sometimes it's clear and convincing and
then sometimes the word une
unequivocal is used so this is this bill
as it stands presently is going to
present problems for pleadings uh the
other things are that um in terms of
service uh a copy of and I'm looking at
section three a copy of the motion shall
be personally served upon respondent Pro
personal process server or as provided
by law or by any Sheriff procedurally
speaking uh there are two ways you can
look at it one if you're bringing a new
case on petition for contempt typically
once they're filed they come with
instructions for service by the
petitioner or plaintiff and they tell
them how to do it right in there and
it's uh right the notice from the court
and they give them dates to serve and
they say it's going to have to be served
by a sheriff uh so they have
instructions in there uh the because
it's kind of a little schizophrenic but
in the nature of things if you have an
existing case and you file a motion for
contempt service on a party or by mail
is usually sufficient um or it can be in
hand where where whereas when you're
bringing a new petition or a new case or
opening another case for a petition for
contempt uh and if I'm straying here
please bring me back in So when you
bring a new petition for a case you were
required to make inhan service and that
differs from a bode service primarily
due to the nature of uh the proing
itself because it can result in
incarceration the um speaking of
incarceration this bill does not refer
to incarceration as a potential penalty
um frankly I think it's a deterrent
effect uh to include possible
incarceration for willful non-compliance
of court orders um this is going to
sound a little bit strange perhaps but
there may simply not but there is a
reluctance on the behalf of the
Judiciary in my opinion to um issue what
are called show cause orders unless the
behaviors is very egregious um if you
have the kind of egregious behavior I'm
hearing as been testified to
incarceration May simply be a remedy now
incarceration is not meant to be
punitive but it's B to do two things
first if it's a civil contempt as this
is very well may be it's usually
designed to uh Co it's coercive in
nature and the idea of a contempt is
coercive to bring that party in
compliance now uh and if it's a civil
cont if it's a criminal contempt it's
usually done to vindicate the authority
of the Court um and they have a
completely different set of due process
standards so I think this could be
clarified and I think what the intent of
this could be done could be to roll this
in to um into the upcoming bill and when
I think it comes time I see I think you
would see that with a couple of small
amendments it could be done fairly
easily the other part of it is is that
um you don't want to paint yourself I
don't think we we if we're interested in
the administration of justice want to
paint ourselves into a corner uh which
means that this is the sole remedy and
if you don't have it in the statute it's
not there um other things to look at are
going to be
um the things that are already in this
statute already exist as Equitable
remedies uh within with with a court can
do okay so when you're looking at Upon A
finding I'm assuming you would want uh
preponderance of the evidence uh a court
May order remedies which are can you can
certainly have compensatory
visitation uh you can certainly order
this on an uh to educate the Violator
about the importance of providing that
but that could be done on a case-by
casee basis and that's within the scope
of Equitable remedies courts can do that
um uh assessment of fines um courts can
already order um courts can already
order payment of costs which include a
variety of things depending upon the
egregious nature of the contempt um I'm
not so sure about a bond although I
don't it's not terrible but the
reasonable expenses of denial are
already I think within a Court's ability
to do it
um
and I think that's that's kind of it um
it's I think well intentioned but I
think this is already States what a
court can do and I think it needs some
and and I think it can be worked into
another bill easily I'd be happy to take
any questions uh for the audience
purposes both here and viewing uh it is
my custom when we have a time limit to
give a much broader time limit to a
person who is in opposition generally to
the bill uh that makes it fair we have
two equal times then anyone else
testifying however they uh wish
whichever side uh goes on the clock so
for those of you wondering why um you
were allowed much greater time that is
why oh
any uh question representative McMahon
thank you Mr
chairman attorney is it marel or marel
maral maral thank you sir as long as
it's not late for dinner
I'm understood attorney maral I
appreciate your description on the
interpretation of uh penalties for La of
a better term um under Section Five uh
within the proposed Bill and you did
refer to line 27 briefly mhm but but in
the last line where it does give the
court of law the powers relating to
penalties of contempt would that uh does
that not speak to given that flexibility
based on the interpretation dur of the
of the court on what an what an
appropriate U um remedy punishment or
remedy would would be good question the
answer is yes and no like most things in
law let me explain uh it's unfortunately
true uh so for example um personally not
enough people are aware of the fact that
uh that they that if you're in contempt
of court you can be incarcerated for
violation of a court order and frankly I
think it satisfies notice an opportunity
to be heard and particularly notice as
to what the sanctions are that you
better think twice before you start
violating court orders so the remedies
may include incarceration is not
available that idea so for example when
you look and they and so for example
when you look at a Massachusetts summons
to appear on a contempt action the
summons also indicates for which you may
be incarcerated okay so in other words
if it goes into the law that you may be
incarcerated people presume to know the
law I think would look at that and say
maybe I'd better think twice before I
started violating it because right now
um people violate orders and they do it
and because there are no consequences no
discernable consequences and I'm not
saying you incarcerate people for no
reason whatever but I can but and but
the process is usually this if somebody
files for a contempt all right and if
the behavior is sufficiently or if the
conduct is sufficiently
egregious uh what you would find is the
court will then if it's by a judge uh
put the case on for what's called a show
cause hearing and a show cause is you'd
better tell us why you ought not to be
held you ought not to be taken into
custody uh and that's usually the way it
works so I'm a fan of including
incarceration in there because it may
well give people notice and uh May
prevent a lot of the contumacious
conduct that
occurs one followup one follow up thank
you just one attorney marel um
appreciate your guide in that regard and
specific to that uh with the existing
law being in play as you described is it
not redundant then to put it into
another bill or is that yes it is it
redundant redundant and it's done
because of prosay this is for for easier
access for Citizens utilizing this
versus using an attorney well you don't
really I get it good question um it's
good that that provides notice but this
these are already existing remedies okay
so for example the one thing about
divorce law and family law is that
basically these are what are called
Equitable proceedings and Equitable
proceedings means that the court can do
what's right just or Fair uh you know
some of the complaints that we hear
going up are for example uh from an AG
grieved party on a divorce proceeding is
the Court ruled this way and I disagree
with it but as long as there's an
objective basis below okay the the
actions taken below assuming they're
within bounds are going to be affirmed
on appeal now to directly answer that
Equitable remedies what's right what's
just what's fair okay so if you're an AG
grieved party a court can already do
this and uh so it's going to be what are
what remedies are and that's what they
are I hope I answered that question if
not please ask me
another any further questions
repres uh chair Vice chairman L uh thank
you Mr chairman uh attorney Markel do do
you have articulated or written uh to
what you would recommend we look at um
you yes well already okay well I'll tell
you what I do have that might be helpful
to you and I'm jumping the gun a little
here because I have a presentation I'm
finishing up for the next bill that's
coming up um what I planned to do was
bring in a copy of an ambiguous court
order okay that supports the notion that
contempts need to be unambiguous number
one number two I have a I'm going to I
plan to present a redacted order for a
show cause hearing to show you what the
egregious nature of conduct really is
from a real Court in a recent hearing uh
to show you what would be worthy of
incarceration number three I have a i i
in November of
2023 I published a New Hampshire Barn
news article on this on the necessity of
putting a statute forward uh which
briefly summarizes the history of
contempt and I do have copies of that
for you right now if you would like to
see them uh of that particular article
which summarizes content would you like
me to get them uh after you're done you
can hand them to representative Bickford
thank you okay um one followup one
followup we're going to be moving on
then uh with respect to uh this this
appeals RSA uh
461 a colon 4 a mhm um which any motion
for contemporary
enforcement uh of an order shall be
reviewed within 30 days correct yeah do
you see is this is this minimizing
what's current there or do they pretty
much look the same well it's it's going
to minimize it the one thing is that we
do have some redundancies uh built into
statute we have RSA for 58 I think it's
51 which deals with contempt but does
not define what a contempt is it says
contempt in domestic relations matter
and then Awards attorneys fees where
where takes away discretion legislature
takes away judicial discretion and says
on a finding of contempt the court shall
award uh attorneys fees and
costs um so we can alter that the other
Pro the other thing is is that you have
I'm going to say it's RSA I'm going to
say 461 a15 I think it's 15 I'm not sure
where it says a party who with
unreasonably fails to comply with a
court order okay
uh gets themselves in trouble now
there's the difference between the
unreasonably fails to follow standard
and
content uh unreasonable fails to follow
is vager it's a little
softer um but it do and it does not NE
necessarily address the same issue
because they're two completely different
things okay you know the difference for
example between a motion to enforce
might not necessarily be a willful and
intentional act the other thing that we
don't have here is is that whether or
not you have an ability to comply either
past or present so in the future
proposed statute we have an ability to
comply uh so that narrows the pleadings
and a prosay who looks at that okay and
a lawyer who looks at that can then say
okay this is how I plead my case a pro
can look at it and say this is how I
plead my case you know they did this
they did this they did this and they had
the ability to comply and they didn't
comply or it was this this and this and
this and you can sign off on it judges
will no longer have to Cobble together
and go to and go to case law and look at
protocols to be able to Cobble together
something because they can look right at
the statute and say this is what it is
you're in contempt or you're not in
contempt
okay thank you good thank you thank you
for your testimony and now we uh having
heard the prime sponsor and having heard
one who checked his card as opposition
we've got the remaining cards and we
will be going into a 3 minute and 30
second drill and we've already seen how
good we are at that and the chair
recognizes again uh Mr Tim
penac P sir
pen a saac pen a saac yes okay so a soft
SE got it okay thank you thank you uh
thank you chairman Parsons I appreciate
your time uh again um I won't for the
sake of brevity I will not repeat some
of the issues associated with my
particular case the challenge as similar
to Mr Al's situation is all of this is
great and good except when the excuse my
vacular because I spent 11 years in the
military when the rubber hits the road
because the impact of what actually
happens versus the spinning of language
is a very difficult situation for a
parent who is fighting to get their
children my ex-wife was a arrested in
December I filed immedately an exp parte
motion um the the motion was was denied
and then they assigned a hearing 90 days
she was arrested for failure to comply
with um the inter appearance um uh
statute it was the misdemeanor side not
the not the um not the felony side she
refused to exchange the children right
the hearing was set 90 days out we got
in we got in the process of getting the
hearing so I lost my kids for n for 90
days God in the process of the hearing
her attorney filed for a
continuance and that continuance was
pushed another 90 days so I was six
months without seeing you know arguably
two of my three kids my eldest my eldest
son was away in college um at that point
in time my ex-wife had imparted a level
of I'll use the term brainwashing on my
daughters my son came to live with me
because he was suffering so much from
emotional abuse and that he was he was
somewhat suicidal so the issue at hand
is the timing of things in the forcing
the court to move rapidly and quickly in
order to address these issues that is my
challenge with this W with the fact that
if we split hairs on the language we're
not moving quickly the court needs to
move quickly the court needs to
understand exactly what the penalties
are put in place and make that happen
because as it was I was seen by marital
Master dpra there's a situation with
marital Master dpra he resigned we were
assigned another judge and then it was a
year a year until from the incident
until we had a meaningful Hearing in
front of the court right I I am now 3
years into that my daughters come back
to me for a periods periods of time I
was given at the beginning of the of of
the divorce a 50-50 relationship I have
my girls I see my girls about 25% of the
time 20% of the time at best now we are
third year into it we are waiting from
the order from the court that happened
in November 20 that hearing happened in
November 22nd of last year still don't
have that hearing out right I'm
expecting fully expecting after a g was
involved in all a lot of infighting
associated to this that the court will
award back to 5050 30 seconds yes sir
thank you so we are three years into
this and guess what happened yesterday
she violated the the parenting order not
the agreement the parenting order from
the court last night she refused to
exchange the girls so I'm back into the
same situation the challenge is the
timing of the Court the timing of being
able to effectively say stop it you know
this both parents have time with their
children you cannot do this I agree the
the idea of incarceration that'd be a
wonderful thing but truly do I want my
do my daughter's um mother arrested and
thrown in jail that's going to make the
situation much worse for me personally
so I I think there's a balance of
following the court or following the law
and the reality of a parent working with
their children thank you sir thank you
sir any
questions and thank you for bringing
this before us you've dramatized well
the Need for Speed thank you sir and Mr
Robert tangu tangue excuse
me excuse me thank you um I'm asking
your guys' help uh with some questions I
I do know quite a bit about uh family
cour Court uh rule 1.2 right if you read
the family court rules rule
1.2 a judge May
wave upon good cause any rule that's
right unless prohibited by law so I'm in
support of this bill because it kind of
guides but also
restrains the very very
new judges in a very very new court
system special Court Family Court
created in 2005 the Family Division the
family court was created in
2011 and it's basically been terrorizing
Pro lians since its
Inception
um I'd like to speak about 633 colon 4
interference with custody there is a
misdemeanor offense in which you hide
the children uh from a parent and you
can argue that 633 is actually it say if
you read the language a a parent if that
that means even if you have court
orders saying that there's custody at
this time but if you hide the
location I assert that you have the
right to know where your children are at
any point in time so it's a felony when
it's over the state and there's no
justification not preventing the abuse
of the child nothing you have to within
72 hours if you're going to hide the
location of a child from a parent which
happened in my case with a police
officer uh and the police don't do
anything about it it you the amount of
pain that someone suffers when they're
children are removed from
their understanding you can see this
in slips uh permission slips you can't
take your children the school can't take
their children on a field trip you have
to know where your children are at all
times and that's the the way it works so
this bill gives the court clear
guidelines lines and the litigant clear
guidelines to do a
simple procedure and the court does
have decision-making ability whether or
not to impose that fine and and so they
do have but it they can't wave that
right where if you file contemp motions
I file contemp motions just not
regarding to this um it's it's an
important bill uh I do not think that
there should be jail time put on that uh
because then that leaves the court to
abuse a unpreferred litigant yeah to
jail time is it's a it's a big thing man
you have to really do a crime and if you
read the legal statutes um 30 seconds
thank you and I will uh state that in my
case uh so when you look at 173b is
unconstitutional right of the accused um
that's domestic violence protection uh
and 633 col 4 is a form of domestic
violence
when you're ordered to do things uh with
the
court I'm going to run out of time uh so
maybe we'll have to save that for later
but I do support this bill um I don't
really see any amendments that are
necessary and I'm open to any questions
that you might have about 633 col 4 or
the court rules contempt process because
I am familiar with that sure any
questions for Mr
tangu come on guys all right it's the
rules yeah but you get one more bite at
the Apple
today thank you sir and
um former representative Betty gay 3
minutes and 30 seconds you asked for
three I'm giving you
330 thank you very much for taking my
testimony children need timely responses
when it comes to time with their parents
and to me one of the basic things that
this bill provides since which I really
support is that it provides a shortened
time for delay anytime the parents are
not sharing equally so uh the RSA Force
a4a is repealed by this bill uh by this
bill um I'm sorry I'm really
nervous RSA 461 a4a is any motion for
contempt or enforcement of an order
regarding an approved parenting plan
under this chapter if filed by a parent
shall be
reviewed by the court within 30 days
there's two real problems with with that
little paragraph it only says they're
going to review it doesn't say they're
going to do anything about it and it's
within 30 days and unfortunately we know
the 30 days usually lengthens and can
turn into 90 which can turn into
months so this bill is specific IT
addresses with a fast response 10 days
is a much better
response and it's addressing an issue
that police always tell
me if somebody calls me because their
other parent won't give their child up
we can't do anything and one of the
Chiefs said to me I'm not going to take
a child who doesn't want to go well that
puts him in the position of being a
psychologist because we all know
children have to uh live with the person
whoever they're living with they're
definitely going to want to please
because it's painful if you don't so it
shouldn't put a policeman in this
position of deciding whether or not that
should be decided by the parenting plan
so if they won't enforce it if child
doesn't want to go the police say to the
parent and I've heard this many times
this is a court matter okay you've
already been to court you have your
parenting
plan why do you have to go back to court
to get a another parenting plan well
apparently you have to go back to court
to file for contempt okay that's another
huge delay of time and what are you
going to do find the other parent guilty
and put him in
jail this is a much more humane way to
deal with the situation there's lots
more things than being put in jail found
being found in
contempt it's reasonable and it's fast
it's fast response and it meanwhile it
means the children are denied did not
denied being with both parents so I
think this is a wonderful bill and I
hope it passes thank you will you take
questions oh sure any
questions seeing none thank you so much
representative ameritus amerita gay and
with that this closes the hearing on
House Bill
10006 and we'll take a few minutes to uh
get our paperwork sorted out
here
good
night
it's an extraordinary only the
most it's not I don't like the way
you
EX
um it's an
old basic
talking
yeah
disect
there's
no
open the hearing on House Bill
1564 relative to the child support
guidelines representative katab from
Windham that is to distinguish her from
all the other representative kabs that
you may see in the course of your
duties thank you Mr chairman and
honorable members of the child and
family law committee again for the
record my name is representative Kaitlyn
cab I'm here to introduce a bill
relative to child support
guidelines just to give a brief history
back in
2007 there was a legislative change that
we could not
deviate from the child support
guidelines based on shared parenting
time
and after that happened the first report
that came out after that the child
support quadrennial report in 2009
immediately changed recommended making
changes to kind of change that back and
then also in 2018 and 2022 in those
reports they've also recommended that we
really need to make changes for this so
I saw that lots of bills have been in
put in over the years to try and address
this and each year they've been ited so
this summer I
worked with several of the stakeholders
who have previously opposed ones that
have previously supported and tried to
come together with a bill that everybody
could agree on so it was in conjunction
with working with several family law
attorneys
mediators um particularly one gentleman
here uh Anthony uh matalo he is is here
to testify as well help to work on this
language and I think it's something that
we can all agree on also uh did speak
with New Hampshire Legal Aid on this as
well and uh New Hampshire Association of
justice so
um when that happened some of the judges
did
immediately listen to that statutory
change but some did not and some
continued to deviate anyway and so some
of the cases became challenged so the uh
Silva V Silva case in 2018 upheld that
again the legis the the statue states
that you can't deviate based on shared
parenting time and so when that came the
judges could no longer
deviate when the Anderson case came in
2019 which was argued
because they had initially deviated and
then when the case came back up when
when they had divorced in 2011 there had
been a deviation based on shared
parenting time but then in 2017 in 2017
when they came forward they didn't allow
for a deviation when the review of the
child support came forward so in 2019
they stated we're going to leave this to
the legislature to fix that was from the
court hearing so I think you
know judges are looking to us to help
them out with this as well so what this
bill does is it
incorporates to allow for some deviation
based on shared parenting time and it
also increases the self-support reserve
from 115% to 130% which has long been
recommended to change and is changed in
many other states so what this does is
that if you have approximately equal
parenting time which means greater than
40%
which equates to
having approximately 5 days over a twoe
period plus 26 days over vacation time
such as you know uh
December uh February and April vacations
and the summer vacation and
so and that you have approximately equal
income which is within 10% of each other
then there's an understanding a
rebuttable presumption a rebuttable
presumption so there may be other
circumstances why this this wouldn't
happen but a rebuttable presumption that
a$0 child support
obligation would be appropriate and the
reason for that is right now if you if
you do if you're sharing 50/50 parenting
time and your child support let's say
parent A's child support order uh comes
out to $2,000 and parent B's child
support order comes out to 2005 that's
out of the calculator how much it
calculates what their shared child
support amount would be
what's happening today is parent B that
came up with a
$205 they would have to pay parent a
$2,005 the full amount and so then they
are unable to afford a lot of their
expenses it's you're on very un even
playing Ground at that point so this
this seeks to help to remedy that and it
gives a few other scenarios as well
where deviations may make sense and
again these are rebuttable presumptions
and there
is language in here for reason about why
it some of these may not make sense such
as significant health issues long
distances between the parents or
unpredictable work schedules or in cases
where there's evidence of abuse as
defined in RSA 173b col
1 the other
um approximately or sorry so uh
substantially shared parenting schedule
was defined as greater than 35% and the
reason of importance of putting that in
was if parents don't live very close and
the kids can't go back and forth on
school nights what that equated to was 4
days over a 2E period plus additional
time during summer and school vacations
would would equal that 35% there
so those are really the things that are
changing again just giving some
rebuttable presumptions to allow for for
deviations with the Shared Parenting and
then increasing that self support
Reserve which has been recommended to be
changed for quite some time I'm happy to
take any questions
I may have heard this incorrectly or not
no was being the choices but um did you
say that um the impetus behind this bill
here was from uh some members of the
Judiciary so it it's been actually
recommended in a few different so in the
Anderson case what they said was we'll
leave that to the legislature to change
if they'd like to um let me tell you
what the exact wording was let me see if
I can quickly pull up the case but um no
the I think the push to change this was
really from the quadral reports and when
they took quite a bit of the
testimony what they heard was many
parents can't
afford to have an
equal um standard of living for the kids
when they're paying so much and they
make about the same as the other parent
makes it's it's creating for really
uneven footing and so as a quadrennial
reports that ultim recommended the
change but also
um in the Anderson case they said
accordingly we leave this is issue to
the legislature so they left it to us to
decide if we wanted to fix it or not
good thank you anyone
else seeing nobody else thank you so
much thank
you chair recognizes um Anthony
matalo
I have an Italian language speak coach
here uh it's the next to the last
syllable How how how do I do he's going
to
tell much family mediator from Derry
he's from the North End of Boston Jo I
want to thank you for allowing me to
testify
today um so I'm a family mediator I've
been a family mediator for about 10
years a little over 10 years and I've
worked with about 800 families um that
have worked that have struggled with
this issue of Child
Support um the current law when I'm
working with people in my office the
current law I can work with the current
law but there are contradictions in the
current law that when people are um
litigating or or not not able to reach
agreement there is there are there are
contradictions in the current law that
lead to unjust results I will tell you
that in the 800 cases that I've worked
on 800 or so cases I have never uh
failed to be able to or my clients have
never failed to be able to reach a
settlement on child support it isn't
that it's easy it isn't that it's um uh
that there's clear guidance in the
current law but what what happens in
that office is that mothers and fathers
use common sense they apply common sense
to come up with an order so what this
bill when I was asked to to contribute
to this bill pretty much what I did
these were not my ideas these were the
ideas of 800 New Hampshire families
who've settled this issue it's not
rocket science and if you apply common
sense it works so what this bill is a
representation of those of of those
families uh
criteria pretty simple to explain if you
have two people who two parents who earn
the same amount of money and they have
the kids the same amount of time there's
generally and they're splitting other
expenses no child support going back and
forth right they have equal resources
equal expenses around the kids if you
have a case where one person earns a lot
more than the other person and has the
kids less amount of the time so less
than a than a substantially shared
parenting schedule in that case the
guideline should apply in cases where
you have the kids an approximately equal
amount of time and there's a difference
in incomes whatever child support is
paid from one parent to the other should
not flip incomes Common Sense every one
of my clients agree with these standards
and then lastly if there's a difference
in
incomes and there is not an
approximately equal parenting schedule
then a deviation from the guidelines may
or may not be appropriate so this is
where parents work
together sometimes they deviate from the
guidelines and sometimes they don't and
it gives this bill would give judges the
same guidelines the same bumpers in the
bowling alley to come to these
conclusions with the Paramount this bill
says the Paramount concern which is
consistent with the current law on the
purpose of child support in New
Hampshire the Paramount concern is
whether with a deviation from the
guidelines the lower earning parent can
provide a substantially similar standard
of living to the because it is the
Studies have shown that what is
important is if children perceive that
both parents are able to provide for
them and they're not living one house in
opulence and the other house in poverty
so so that is what the purpose of this
bill is IT addresses I think all of the
concerns we tried to find something in
the middle of the road that everybody
could get on board with and hopefully
this does that and I'm happy to answer
any questions any
questions seeing none thank you okay
you're very welcome thank you but uh if
if you can stay around and appreciate
that in case something comes up next um
Susan bristen from DHHS B CSS welcome
back and you're here to provide
information DHHS has so much information
and they provide it
too well I only provide the information
from bcss it's a small but deep part oh
we we have yes we have the big boss over
there thank
you good afternoon I'm Susan bristen I'm
the chief uh staff attorney for the
office of Child Support uh here to
provide some in information on House
Bill
1564 um as you know our office did the
quadrennial review that uh all of these
child support bills are are based on and
one of the the major things that the
quadral review looked into is the the
use of deviations in in determining
child support and I think that that's
our concern with with this bill in that
it calls for it actually calls for
deviations um which is not
helpful um I to the court and I also
believe it's not helpful to the public
when they're using uh these guidelines
they're not just for the court to figure
out child support they're actually used
by Council and the public when they're
you know before they bring something to
court to to figure out what their
position should be um and calling for a
deviation um I don't think gives any
guidance to deviation up deviation down
$5
$500 um becomes an issue and and there's
a couple different times it calls for
deviations I'm looking
at
page
two line
four and then page two line 9 through
14 that whole paragraph is talking about
talking about
deviations the change to the self-
support Reserve I think was also called
for in the quadral review and I believe
that's what's called for um in the other
bill as as well um
and I think that's all I
have any
questions representative
McMahon thank
you Miss brist is it attorney bristen it
is thank you want to make sure I had it
correct hold on think sure uh relative
to the de to the
deviation is the
uh with the goal being a shared expense
but between parties earning different uh
incomes is there a is there a uh number
in this in this strategy that you would
recommend would be
appropriate um I think that's that's the
problem it's it's really hard to sort of
figure out where where we're going to
land um the way this is written it
actually if if you're looking at page
page one um line 25 child child care
guidelines and then adjust Ms and it
lays out that if you
have equal child care costs equal
uninsured medical expenses and um equal
agreed upon extracurricular activities
and then you have substantially similar
incomes and approximately equal paren
time then we get to
zero so if you don't hit any of those
you're sort of not in that box to get
zero child
support you can then hit the boxes for
maybe a deviation depending on depending
on where you are and of course in a lot
of these cases there's not agreement I
spent a lot of time with pi I cover uh
cases in in Plymouth and Littleton and
getting people to agree on how much they
spend on various things um can take a
while so I think the the problem with
that is that if you don't have agreement
then you're going to a hearing and the
parties don't agree and then I think we
sort of end up where we are now because
the rest of this bill doesn't change the
child support guidelines as they exist
right now right so I'm not sure it it
gives relief in those types of cases one
followup Mr chair followup thank you Mr
chairman um attorney bristen that uh
with that statement being made and the a
previous commentary by Mr romalo hope I
had that right close
enough following my chair is gu on
vernacular we'll have language lessons
later yes we will
um uh in having a a similar from one
parent to the next uh living condition
and that was described that one may not
be able to provide that without a
sustainable additional Revenue stream
what would you recommend based on your
experience on how to achieve that goal
so that that the Shared Parenting will
have uh uh for the service provided to
the subject the child will be equal or
as close to equal between the
parents well I think that I mean that
language is is helpful in that we don't
have it right now with dealing
with parents and equal type uh living
conditions I'm not
sure it it's a laudable goal I'm not
sure we we'll ever get there um only
because again
there's what's happening in everybody in
each party's households and then there's
what they can prove what they can bring
what they can bring to the court um I
know the courts the courts do
try um I just I wish we
had more guidance than
this proposal gives us with regards to
um different levels of of deviation so
that people would know ahead of time
what the deviation should be and where
would we get that guidance
it would well I I think it should we
should put it in if it was in the in the
law with much more like levels I mean it
sort of starts here but the levels are
only in very very specific circumstances
if in other state statutes that I've
seen become much more um different boxes
and everybody lands in a box as opposed
to this which I think is you have very
boxes for zero zero amount of child
support and then it gets mushy is the
word that comes to mind and then it's
sort of like well it could be this well
it could be that I'm thinking of of
people who come in and want to you know
if I if I get divorced right now what's
my what's my child support going to
be it it's it to me it still feels very
unknown um based on unusual
circumstance no I'll leave it that thank
you attorney pres thank you Mr chairman
and thank you counselor the chair next
recognizes Rebecca Hutchins from uh
Dober and he will call her once uh
representative bigford has been
recognized Mike
on Mr rafon if you don't know him
personally thank you as I as I recall in
the review one of the issues um they had
with New Hampshire is the deviations the
number of deviations and and I I
remember rather High uh percent you
probably remember better than I do um
will this exacerbate that or will this
improve that or leave it about the
say I think it it would lead to more
deviations because it actually CS for
deviations in in the law
um whether that would eliminate other
deviations because of because of certain
things I don't know um but I think I
think it might lead to at least a slight
up uptick in deviations thank
you and
now Rebecca
Hutchins from Dover New
Hampshire but not when she got her cell
phone where's Six
5 it's
what Nashville I was just there rule one
here that we really work hard at is turn
the mic on you have passed rule one
how's that great thank
you uh chairman Pearson and members of
CH uh children and family law committee
uh my name is Rebecca Hutchins I am in
support of making changes to our
legislation to include recommendations
from the quadrennial reviews of the New
Hampshire child support guidelines as
you may have read my written testimony
last week in support of hb1
1595 since first SE seeing the 2018 New
Hampshire child support guidelines
review report I had naively expected
that the state would implement the
recommendations to adopt a shared
parenting
calculation I'm a mom of two and I have
had shared parenting uh since my divorce
in
2018 I've been working with
Representatives Bickford and majori
alongside the National Parents
organization and New Hampshire citizens
to bring 20 plus years of research to
light and to finally include a parenting
time adjustment in our
legislation HB 1564 is a step in the
right direction for the changes that
have been needed for so long I support
two specific aspects of this bill one
increase the self-support reserve to
130% it's currently at 115% above the
National Poverty Level this was noted in
the recommendations of the 2022
quadrennial review as previously stated
uh secondly the bill acknowledges the
need to consider parenting schedules as
a factor in child support orders this
bill helps specific families as it
speaks clearly and plainly to a range of
parents where a0 order would be
appropriate
in situations where parents share
approximately the same amount of time
with their children and they earn a
similar
amount while the bill opens the
conversation for adjustments and other
ranges of income and parenting time it
does not update the calculator so that
families have the tools to easily
navigate the mathematics behind
understanding a fair amount of child
support for shared
parenting without these tools I
personally find these sections confusing
as do other parents that I've shared it
with HB 1595 is a broader look at
parenting time adjustments and
specifically responds to the federal
government's call to action for states
to provide a formulaic approach to child
support guidelines to Res reduce the
exorbitant number of deviations from the
guidelines hb1 1595 does this by
changing the child support calculator to
give the proper tools to our New
Hampshire families and to reach an
appropriate uniform support order this
calculator is in line with the cross-
calculation method used in 42 other
States it also includes a fair method
for sharing medical and child care
expenses as well as includes a parenting
time adjustment the calculation method
does not need definitions of income
brackets or thresholds to avoid Cliff
effects in the
calculation these definitions can be
made into into divisive measures to get
in the way of co-parents working well
together last week chairman Pearson
acknowledged that the two bills exist
and urged the groups to merge the bills
or to find a way to help the committee
pass the changes needed the groups have
met and decided it doesn't make sense to
combine the bills at this time both
bills have enough Merit to stand
independently HB 1564 includes changes
that can help many families without
changing the child support calculator
and the possibility for Swift action is
appealing since our state has a history
of not making the needed changes for
many years HB 1595 can stand without uh
hb564 however it can also be offered as
a companion tool for HB
1564 both the working groups of HB 1564
and 1595 have been working hard to bring
important changes to the state each bill
has has different approaches to bring
that change for these reasons I
respectfully asked this committee to
move both bills forward to benefit New
Hampshire families thank you any
questions representative
Bickford thank you Mr chairman uh do you
want to share with us any of your
background or how you got into this um
certainly so I am a mom of two and I've
been navigating the court for quite some
time
um I included my testimony for 1595
which goes into a little bit more
history but we've been back and forth
through mediators and Court um and had
our parenting uh our our Uso our uniform
support order changed a minimum of six
times since 2018 that's a lot right
normal circumstances job loss incomes
change we need an autonomous way for for
families to navigate this litigation and
mediation is extremely expensive for us
to go back for small changes that happen
regularly to our families I have been in
a situation currently where it's been a
year and a half of in and out of court
to have an order changed it's been
changed twice temporarily and yet I
still need to go back for a final
hearing this is ridiculous to navigate a
normal
family
situation that's the reason that I've
gotten
involved I uh look at the bottom uh last
sentence of your document I respectfully
ask this committee to move both bills
forward to benefit the Hampshire
families but at the top of the page
while the bill opens the conversation
for adjustments etc etc uh without these
tools I personally find this SE
confusing as to other parents I've
shared with so you like it but there are
parts of the bill that do the job for
specific families for families that
currently don't have a law that says
it's okay to have zero support when we
have similar parenting time and we have
similar uh incomes this bill does that
the current section for deviations in
our law RSA 258 C5
doesn't allow for families to deviate or
recognize that shared parenting alone is
a reason for our child support numbers
to be different than what our current
calculator spits
out
hb564 begins to pave the way for people
to do that okay so for those reasons I
appreciate their attempt to change the
law without changing the calculator
later so it's a good step forward you
wanted another step but you take the win
I I will take the win and I think we
still need to update the calculator okay
any other
questions and in case I forget at the
end of the hearing we will not be
working to exec these bills for a couple
to three weeks and if things that have
been shared in the hearings resonate
with uh definitely the prime sponsor or
any of the other sponsors it gives us
the opportunity to tweak and amend if we
choose so thank you for your testimony
apprciate appreciate it
and are you native to
Nashville I'm hearing round O's you're a
little further Northwest are
you Long Island okay I thought I heard
of Minnesota
o all right representative Betty gay
please
please thank you for letting me give
testimony
um my opinion I'm I'm sharing my opinion
from hearing for years that the child
support collection part of the state of
DHHS is rewarded on a percent basis by
the federal government for doing the
service of
collecting the more so what I understand
is the more they collect the more
Federal money comes in well we all know
we want our budgets to be as healthy as
possible so I want to suggest that one
of the reasons
underpinning the a uh State not being
really thrilled with a just
um changing the rules is because they
might end up collecting less money
instead of two parents paying each other
instead of subtracting one from the
other that can be a reason that they're
not really happy to see some new rules
that hopefully will cut down on how much
people have to pay in so that it just
makes the the living conditions for the
child more equal from P both
parents
um I know there's another
point oh in addition to getting funding
from the federal government as a reward
for collecting the parents have to pay a
percentage for the service of having
their money collected and
dispersed so I find this burdensome for
the parents I both received child
support and I paid child
support um so many years were between
the two that I ended up paying as almost
as much for one as I receive for two but
that was not the issue the point is I
don't think the parents should have to
be paying for this service especially
after they're getting um re getting
rewarded by the federal government and
if they're not if they're going to
suffer Lo losing a lot of funds from the
federal government by allowing people to
pay less to stay as equal as
possible
um then they're going to be paying less
I I just think that this is a very this
bill is a very positive move to make
things more Equitable for the parents
and lessen the need to go to court which
if you haven't gone to court
recently you don't realize just how
devastating the costs are to your to
your
income thank you any questions of The
Honorable fetty
gay seeing none thank you so
much and we're coming coming into the
gun lap and attorney J marel yes sir I
got it yes thank you and I'm going to
limit you to five minutes please because
the weather outside isn't continues to
be bad and you're on board with the bill
so you have less negative to bring to it
that I didn't mean it that way you have
less other opinion to bring is what I
meant so thank you sir okay thank you um
generally supportive um just a couple of
suggestions that you may wish to
consider I'm looking at uh page two and
I'm looking from lines one down through
14 just as a preface nothing in the
current law prevents anybody with
substantially equal parenting time or
any other reason uh prevents the court
from issuing two simultaneous uniform
support orders for the parents one
parent can actually be ordered to pay
one parent and another parent can be
ordered to pay another parent which
leads me to the believe because that's
the whole in the current statute uh so
when I look at page two uh basically
what you're dealing with here is is that
you can deal with what's called the
child support offset which I mentioned
last time which was basically in very
common use prior to uh the Silva
decision uh as I as I think you've
already heard the Silva decision
rendered basically an unfair what a
widely perceived unfair result where
parents with approximately equal
parenting time uh with a disparity of
income which was never defined in the
legislature and never defined um in
Silva because the court couldn't add
words to the legisl to legislation so
that was unfair so this seeks to remedy
that the remedy I think can be more
concisely put from those pages right
there into using the offset formula to
be able to um to be able to represent
the best interests of the children when
you have a finding by a judge that it
does comport with the that it comp that
it does represent the best interest of
the children and is agreed to by the is
either ordered by the court or agreed to
by the parents that would be the
amendment I would make it would probably
make it a little easier for people to
work
with that okay ends my question so if
anybody has any thank you any
questions no thank you sir thank you and
chair recognizes Mr Robert
tangu
right
thank you I say Let It Snow it's all
good um I am opposed to this bill
actually respectfully because of um I
know the hard work that's been put into
it however um as I've stated before uh
but not really in in directly into this
bill um there's a statute on the books
from the uniform support Act of
uh
which states that basically assets shall
be considered um as The Honorable Betty
Gil just uh uh gave I'm sorry it was
getting back into the 50s uh stated is
that the child
support group gets their uh I mean the
states get funding by the amount of
child support that they
award
and therefore they want to award child
support
and that's just wrong I I don't think
that child support is something that
should
be uh
awarded and then when you look at how
the laws actually applied we have
standing laws where it says assets shall
be considered the the relative
uh wealth is the specific term of the
individual families
um that's already there and that should
be on the child guidelines worksheet and
it's not so that's why I don't and I
also don't support a bill that
acknowledges
173b domestic violence protection orders
civil because it's against the
Constitution Article 15 of the
Constitution of the State of New
Hampshire rights of the accused says
that in order to take away any
privileges property anything you have to
go through due process meaning you need
an arrest so that's saying part of this
Bill is saying that this will apply
unless there's domestic violence by the
way 173b is unconstitutional and it's
being used to
strategically get and get the person
who's claiming domestic
violence uh money child support time
complete control of the
children uh verification of the record
and also like def
like they they put these things that are
false um and it's also you know before
the special committee uh chair Pearson
um we actually heard the famous judge
poly case in which the police did not
arrest the person who ended up shooting
her in the face and also the domestic
violence Coalition never showed up to
the final protection order so the police
failed to follow the law when there was
signs of physical and sexual abuse there
was evidence of and they said go file a
civil protection order so we need to be
working
on repealing
173b and enforcing the
police to arrest people who violate the
laws and then we need to be
acknowledging laws that
state that child support shall be shall
be considered by who uh the General
assets of of and wealth of the
individual parties the ability to earn
and so on and then we also have to
consider that in some cases child
support is not necessary in any which
manner the CH what a parent spends their
money on for their children is a free
speech it's been acknowledged and
political contributions federally it's
free speech if I want to buy my child
a ring dding I can if I want to buy them
a library book I can if I don't want
them to have a brand new
iPad I shouldn't have to if I don't want
to pay the mother's
mortgage because she wanted to end a
relationship you got
left okay so I don't support this Bill
thank you and
um for those reasons stated and I just
want to really uh hammer in that once
73b is unconstitutional I'm challenging
it with the attorney general and uh the
state and we shouldn't be using
funding uh for federal money
to basically
Force payments through the state and
there's actually a Constitutional
Amendment which I I was trying to look
up uh that says basically we can't the
state can't uh take property away from
someone else for the use of of public
use which that's what child support is
and that's what I'll contend but ums I
want you all to be safe and really look
at
546 and really understand the the spirit
of Child Support was designed to get uh
real deadbeat parents typically dads
that had a one night stand and had a
baby and then ran away that's what child
sport was for thank you so much any
questions for Mr
tangu come on guys this is good stuff I
mean you've got a good sparring partner
here well we know you I think they're in
agreement that's why and they know it's
so true oh well I know you'll be back so
we'll work on some things for you I
appreciate you all we're taking next
Tuesday off go vote thank you and with
this we conclude the hearing on um House
Bill
1564 and if representative McMahon and
Bickford could consolidate the
individual package of things with the uh
researcher supplied paper clips and put
the person's name on the packet and put
them in their mailbox next door please
that way they'll have
them what's that
don't I don't know I never go in
there